the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
s were ticking and pieces were flying at
the Superbad rapid and Blitz in Warsaw
Poland the first day of Blitz was
bursting with energy from the excited
fans in the venue to the world-class
Grand Masters on the stage reigning
world Blitz Champion Magnus Carlson
reminded the field that he is indeed the
number one chess player on the planet
storming up the standings leaving
destruction in his wake to come within
Striking Distance of the leader with
nine rounds left the tournament is wide
open who will claim the Ultimate Prize
don't boinker you'll miss it day five of
exhilarating chess coming up next
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
welcome back everybody to the final
championship day here in Warsaw Poland
at the 2023 Superbad rapid and Blitz
it's been a fantastic event so far
filled with Trails as bills but today is
finally time to Crown a champion who
will that be let's go to the studio and
find out
we welcome you to the second step on the
2023 grandchester tour and our coverage
of Superbad Poland we come to your life
from the San Luis chess club
[Music]
good morning and welcome everyone thank
you for joining us I'm International
mastronastic and I'm here with
Grandmaster yesterday as always I agree
with you to call of the accent this is
the championship day as Christian was
just mentioned Magnus Carlson
finish with five wins yesterday what to
say so impressive hello everyone thank
you for sharing your day with us it has
been great and the blitz has delivered
in Spades take a look at this decisive
number of games from round one all the
way through round nine you see it right
there that we started with four
victories out of the five games you go
all the way to round nine every day
every game was the size of a total of 73
the players are swinging for the fences
which has meant that the standings are
then changing dramatically each and
every round now so do the honors and
tell us who's leading let's take a look
after nine rounds of Blitz we have young
Christoph Dura in the lid with 17 and a
half points it's a precarious lead
though it's only a half a point only
half Point ahead world number one Magnus
Carlson and closely following two
Americans Wesley I live on Iranian also
have points behind the gaps are very
narrow and also in the clear fifth place
Maxima Sheila grab also just half a
point behind Levon fantastic tell us
about the format it's Blitz baby trying
to play around Robin with five minutes
and 2 second increment with a
traditional scoring system 1.4 win half
half for a draw and zero for loss uh no
draw offers and tell us about the
schedule for this the championship day
today's the final day and the players
will be playing the blitz rounds for
game 10 to 18. Fantastic a little bit
more about the playoffs if necessary
make it the playoffs if there are two
players tied at the end they will play
two-game rapid match with 10 minute 5
Second increment okay but if there are
three players or more tied then they'll
have a rapid round robin
five minutes plus three seconds and if
they're still tight we get an Armageddon
wow that would be really something if we
go all the way to playoffs in Armageddon
or as always my friend good to see you
in studio and tell us about the blitzers
who's best if day one of the blitz good
to see you guys it was a very exciting
first day of Blitz and some players did
really really well Magnus Carlsen
winning the five games in a row and now
it's only half a point behind Duda
anything can happen here so that's why
it's very exciting let's take a look at
the top scores in the blitz section so
Magnus scored seven out of nine Wesley
five and a half but Kirito shivchenko a
little bit surprising but we know he's
an excellent Blitz player so he scored
five and a half out of nine very
impressive by kiril
let's take a look at his line score
yesterday so he had two losses but end
up with four wins winning that last game
so very very strong result thank you
real
and Wesley we know he's an excellent
Blitz player he had a more of a solid
day he made a lot of draws in Blitz but
one last three wins and he's very very
dangerous in this format
and now Magnus I think Magnus has a good
chance here only half a point behind
Duda but we have nine more exciting
Blitz Games and we're gonna go to Poland
to our friends Anastasia and Christian
thanks VAR and welcome back chess fans
to the final and Championship day here
at the 2023 super bad rapid templates
and what an event it has been so far but
I have to say yesterday it was all about
the former world champion Magnus Carlsen
just an incredible performance and he
started slowly we were talking with Gary
here in the studio he was saying he's
not in shape we were not seeing the
Magnus Carlsen that we got to know so
well but after that in those last final
five games just an incredible
performance bang bang bang bang just an
incredible game we do that in that final
game taking down the leader and getting
closely behind him only half a point
behind him and we got to connect with
him and chat with him a little bit take
a look
Magnus you started the day three points
Behind The Duda now you're only half a
point behind do that and you're actually
surprised by that
yeah I mean I didn't I made like a
conscious effort not to look at the
standings all day partly because it's
nicer to look at it when you're when
you're when you're doing well but um
yeah obviously now it's um anyone's game
those are some world champion
psychological tricks that he's employing
Anastasia you got to spend some time
with Magnus as well tell us a bit about
that yes yes there was another trick as
well yesterday uh after the games
everybody went to the soccer match and
the Magnus kept scoring you know he
never stops no matter what he plays
actually I think he scored a couple of
goals right and then also I know that
the Christian also did really great job
and the grand Masters beat the organizer
7-3 so this was the final score so you
can see now on the video of Magnus and
the other players actually where olivon
aronian came Maximus was there yes we
had so much I had a lot of fun watching
you guys and it was really nice
yes it was a good assist good assist by
Magnus Christian you're in a good shape
and actually Magnus answered he shared
our story in Instagram and he had
answered that it's always ready to
assist you Christian it was so nice to
see him actually to see this moment yes
he's a very good player of course he's
he runs well I think he controls the
ball very well he's good at sports he
generally enjoys playing these type of
things yeah yeah and that it shows us
yes he has interest to football and by
the way everybody should remember to
follow our social media accounts you
will get really more information and
some Side Stories which we don't share
always in the in the show so please
follow us in Instagram account
grantchester Twitter account and
Facebook as well nine rounds of super
exciting chess coming your way from
Warsaw Poland guys back to you in this
video never mind that seven to three I
heard in the soccer great representation
of the grand Masters and let's remind
everybody about the grand chess tour for
a second and the standings as uh this
run the second event comes to uh close
our Leader's not here yes Fabian is not
playing in this event but he is the
leader of the granchester uh points it's
13 points and the second place sharing
alireza fioruja Wesley so anishkirion
Richard Robert all sharing 7.5 points
that's why I picked Anish Gary I thought
he was going to do great in this second
event maximum Christopher with four and
a half points and the new world champion
league Loren with three points and Yanni
Palm she was two languishing there and
they've been fighting very hard what
have they been fighting for in Poland uh
they're fighting for a nice price fund
the first place winner is going to get
forty thousand dollars second place
thirty thousand third place twenty five
thousand a hundred and seventy five
thousand in total prizes all the way
down to seven thousand for tenth place
there's the GCT points if you win clear
first you'll get a bonus of one point so
that would be 13 points you share first
you start dividing 12 points the player
with the most GCT points at the end of
the tour picks up a hundred thousand and
here's a wild card that's looking to
steal some of those GCT points uh VAR
absolutely they won't hit a great uh
start and then yesterday he was also
actually leading at some point if you
remember guys yes but he had a really
tough finish losing two games in a row
and now he he's he's behind but with a
couple of wins in a row he can get back
into this let's just refresh our
pairings uh Nancy do the our lives and
lay the table for round ten right around
against Carlson absolutely that's an
easy one dude I against rapper yeah
that's Plan B and Iranian against Gary
plan C uh MBL versus
Magnus and that is going to be a huge
game a key game because as we know mvl
can also go on a tear and if you start
against Magnus and you beat Magnus you
just feel like okay this day belongs to
me so this is actually going to be a
very key game and do the same come on
envo yeah there's no somebody stop this
guy dude there's no bigger confidence
boost than beating Magnus absolutely
absolutely so that will be great again
due to just a half a point B uh ahead
and here we have ceremonial first move
sure who's making it
D4
it's a little shaky there I thought it
was going to drop on D3
another one another D4 very very popular
CEO of Superbad Colin Adam London
[Applause]
as we hear the gong and we are underway
again this is it this is the
championship day we will be crowning a
champion will it be Duda who is the
defending champion and it looks like a
karaoke I love to Sid yes we're all very
eager the advanced Carl with Bishop F5
H4
here H5 has become very very popular in
the old days
Queen D7 was a David bronstein idea
Bishop D3
I used to play both H6 and H5 me too
tags
uh E6 is the most standard but we have
been seeing Queen A5 check and queen A6
right our liquid Exchange
kind oftentimes end games are preferable
for black but here's the question Bishop
D2
Queen A6
and should I play E6 remember the the
the the great game uh mvl versus dingler
in where he he got in this incredible
binder please look that up okay
yeah one of the great modern uh
masterpieces I would say uh he can play
six here too right yes after 92. yes we
see it on the board
well E6 VAR I've always thought that
these positions were actually dangerous
for the second player yes I think this
looks a little bit risky because that G5
score is very weak as well so Knight can
land on G5 Knight GF gf3 and then Knight
G5 exactly yeah so I think it's yeah
it's something that you want to try to
avoid if possible
um but with the exchange of the light
score we should the structures the two
double pawns as well you know gives
black some chances as well there was
another alternative after in the move
Queen A5 check guys there is another
idea there B4 in this position so this
actually has been played several times
idea just to sacrifice and get the B
file for The Rook
ibd2 you have Rook B1 now and also
you're threatening the move E6 it also
avoids the queen exchange right yes yes
okay interesting so the current current
position though VAR at the what did the
statistics tell us in terms of
uh who wins most often I have only four
games in my database there were two wins
for white one for black and a one draw
here so but looks like white is better
here very comfortable Advantage Knight
is going to come to H3 next and then you
can have options to go to G5 perhaps
also to go to F4 you know very easy to
play for white and looks like black
needs a lot of moves to finish
development and also try to consolidate
the position so we can check now some of
the key lines here after Knight H3 the
best movies to play rookie 8 was one of
the suggestions but he played Knight F5
now Knight ag3 so here you have to
choose actually to go to G8 or E8 it's
it's not easy to make this decisions
because your Rooks are going to be
probably stuck on the last rank for a
while and it's going to be hard to
connect them so let's say if you go King
8 just Castle
and you need to get the bishop out so
perhaps G6 yeah but then Knight D6 comes
in it's very unpleasant now threading
the move Knight C7 so now you have to
respond either to play Rook C8 or come
back now with King F7 but King F7 will
allow the check so let's let's see let's
see it sure now rookie one comes in okay
and now you can play Bishop G7 right you
really want to put the bishop on F6 here
this will protect E7 and also control a
little bit of the G5 so but here white
can actually just capture the bishop wow
and I've take back and another
interesting idea is to play A4 gaining
space and also you have B3 Bishop A3
idea a lot of problems with this E7 Pawn
here right right here white has a very
big advantage
yes similar idea but maybe avoiding the
potency of Knight C7 for just a moment
parking the King on G8 is Magnus and
again
Bishop Bishop but I that was an
intriguing idea of Knight takes G7 I
wouldn't have just wanted to give up
this powerful knight on E6 so uh lightly
but I like the resulting position for
white I mean everything would be fine
for black if only that Rook on h8 could
get out exactly exactly
um I don't know if we have the head the
head between these two players but it
seems to me that they must have a lot of
games between them
imagine how many games have played
exactly and we do see something similar
to what you were saying Vari the the the
the bishop
got out but uh that that was a big
difference I think King G8 was much
better timed than Kimmy eight uh still
taking the bishop is important very
important not to allow the mubishi F6
and that's what mvl did he took and it's
now you have options where to put the
bishop you can put it on G5 you can put
it on F4 double up the Rooks a lot of
pressure still I don't see a way how
black can really equalize here in the
next let's say 510 moves so it's just
going to be a lot of Defense he has to
he has to do but it it it it's so
strange to me these double pawns you
you'd think well wait a minute that
there should be a way of
getting some play against them but for
the moment it's very hard for black to
put any pressure on these pawns and as
you say once the bishop just comes out
it's it's a lot of pressure that black
will
happen those double pawns will ever
eventually get exchanged if black plays
C5 to activate the Knight
oh he goes actually I like magnus's plan
for K8 and going A4
yeah well he's searching for counter
play and again these these pawns uh it's
not so easy to Target them
um
it feels like uh mvl is the one uh
calling the shots here uh for absolutely
white is better but he I I also like
this okay idea trying to create some
ideas with A4 and A4 was I think a good
reaction to prevent that but now we see
a little bit of weakness on B3 and
Naruto k6 Rook B6 one thing Magnus has
going that even if he loses let's say
the E7 pawn and they get into a position
with one Rooks and Knight he can always
try to create threads with the move Rook
P6 attack on B3 and then Rook B4 comes
in so he's going to have a lot of
chances even in some positions if he
let's say even drops the E7 pawn and
when we saw him yesterday The Rook A6
Rook D6 Rook D7 that was crazy yes
[Music]
that was remarkable he likes this rookie
six ideas
um bar is it makes sense to park the I
was about to say does it make sense to
park the pawn on on E6 or should we just
leave it as long as possible on the E7
Square I would keep it on E7 just to
control a couple of dark squares the F6
and D6 square but E6 was also playable
okay so again evaluation is around plus
one for white but it's it's not getting
uh you know bigger at the moment so
black definitely has some play here with
the weakness on D4 and B3 now we see the
maneuver Bishop coming in on D2 to try
to force a rook back on the A6 and also
control that B4 Square which is very
important because black would love to
play the move Rook before at some point
to attack on D4 so now he has to go back
we're not going to switch games but I've
been told that due to our tournament
leader in a bit of trouble early in this
the 10th round of the blitz so I see
that in this position
I think there's oh D4 plus I mean my
Spidey Sense was tingling there Knight
takes D4 Bishop C3
C5 there's a knight Check Yes but at
first I thought oh my gosh he just
blundered a very important Pawn a knight
to E6 defends the pawn there's a fork on
on C7 otherwise Knight f8 would have
been if I'm black I'm dreaming of
trading off the knights because then the
pawn on D4 is weak Knight f8 I see as a
very I'd call that a strategic threat
actually I see that as a very important
move by the way C5 starting to look a
little attractive here I was going to
say earlier so I can definitely say why
it is better on controlling the position
but black is defending everything and
indeed I'm not 100 sure this has gone
the way MVR wanted because it just feels
like the night was better placed on F3
funnily enough on E6 it blocks the rook
and it's just vulnerable to a trade
threat a Threading a threat of trading
um has White's Advantage diminished or
is it still
okay of our it's diminished a little bit
it's still like 0.5 at the moment and I
think trading the knights will
definitely help Magnus because that
night only five is just so nice it is
and there is no way really to remove him
I mean the F3 G4 plan is going to be
extremely hard to do with the H4 Pawn
always hanging so I like how Magnus is
playing so far and now I will Retreats
on F4 trying to avoid that trade okay so
Knight takes D4 does allow Rook takes E7
right King F7 defends the pawn oh excuse
me I just I just had a fantasy of
96 good morning you can play after C5
first you have to play C5 okay then you
can make nice okay C5 oh I I like black
it might be because I like
to play caracon with black but I'm
having this for black yeah now the pawns
on D4 D3 somehow this Knight maneuver
all the way to E6 has not brought white
success absolutely Magnus definitely
like has got some momentum here and also
he's got a nice lead on the clock and uh
now I'm available played rookie five
trying to get some active Contra play
going
and Rook p8 now with the threat of stake
on F4 and open up the B file indeed
because position is quite close then we
know in close positions Knights do
better than Bishops so that Bishop on C3
is not looking good and this last move
rugby
Rook B3 sets up rook A3 and by the way
tell me about the clocks npl has 13
seconds 13 seconds yes and Magnus has
minute and a half whoa whoa whoa whoa
now it's suddenly gotten very serious
for mvl and this last move King H3 how
does it stop Rook A3 or
Rook A3 I think what he's trying to do
yesterday wants to prepare F3 G4 that's
what he just went for G4 directly so
mvl is looking to play H5 undermine the
Knight here's my question of whether I
should play E6 or not
E6 just depends the night to sidestep H5
I could also do Knight G7 it's passive
but stopping a lot of things and maybe
Knight E6 on a good day
I like on F5 because when I play Rook
takes A4 what's better than being one
two you bet I think E7 E6 and I I think
it's easier to play Black's position or
black has a big Advantage here actually
he can play E6 he can play Knight G7 he
can also play the move Knight D6 it's
very hard to play a position like this
in Blitz where you have all these
weaknesses you have to deal with so I
think the clock as well the clock is H
E6 and I think mvl is just falling on
his own sword King is all the way
I I don't believe it I just don't
believe it and by the way Knight G7 also
sets up Knight D7 and Knight F6
this is
interesting he went from H7 yes in order
to stop Knight G5
oh no this is
this is definitely looks good for black
but the clock times clock time nvl 10
seconds Magnus 21.
oh what a fork oh Knight H6 check and
both white Rooks are on pre
and that's a check and very impressive
win for Magnus in a row let's jump to
the Duty game as it's still uh this is
changed Duda is winning completely
winning now is it a checkmate
comment
it looks like he's a piece up at this
pawns and
queen queen
this queen B7 check
I sure that he was winning and made a
mistake but okay well he has they both
have less than five seconds so and yeah
B2 walks into E7 oh my gosh and we're
gonna have Four Queens
uh well we're gonna have two pieces
because yeah this should be a king and
Knight in the ship versus King
can you do this in 10 seconds I've
trained a lot to do it in 10 seconds I
think I can do it I was watching Dania
noraditski do it uh with the company
with increment I can of course without
increment not a chance
and Richie's gonna test his opponent
what are your techno technical skills
like bishop and Knight versus King it's
very simple you have to drive the
inferior King to the corner of your
Bishop color correct so by the way other
yes then we have some updates Wesley so
won his game very important for the
standings uh
deactivated
wow Cairo so that's the wrong Corner
dude is trying to get the king all the
way to h8
look at him he knows what he's he's got
the W yeah I know and there you go
Richie saw enough he says
I see you've played this before uh what
other games are ongoing how does a
ronian versus Anish
oh they're all done so that game was a
draw okay
Wow first round is over wow Magnus I
would play an mvl that stands out but
Duda nonetheless he came into today half
a point lead he still maintained this
half-point lead by virtue of his victory
but the game that we just witnessed MBL
Magnus was scary because he played that
really well I mean mvl came out of the
opening with an advantage but got out
played VAR absolutely he had a nice
Advantage plus one out of the opening
but Magnus just played so well from that
worst position he just this plan of Rook
A8 and then playing A4 Rook A6 Rook B6
and eventually at the right moment where
he had everything under control he
played the move B5 I also like this move
Knight f8 that was an excellent move
just removing the strong Knight only six
I think nvl just played too slowly at
some point and uh and Magnus just
improved and won another game that's now
six in a row for him guys yeah tell us
tell us about some of the other games
please yeah let's take a look at there
are a few games I was looking at Wesley
saw one and it was very impressive
because it looked like an absolutely
equal position for a long time and in
fact they were repeating at some point
in this end game but finally it was this
position it looks like just equal here
but Wesley didn't want to repeat so he
avoided the Kingsley to play King A2 and
here he went for this breakthrough with
F5 I like this idea because he is behind
he needs to score wins and he took his
chances here so this came as a surprise
here he created some weaknesses and uh
a few moves later we see this this end
game where actually Knight versus Bishop
is better for white here because you
have weaknesses on H5 and F6 you're
probably still holding this position but
it's more unpleasant you have some
weaknesses you have to work with and
very quickly he actually managed to win
this position now he played the move
Knight D5 and allowing the Knight to
jump in was the big mistake you had to
play the move Bishop B3 to control the
D5 square but instead he played this
move and after 95 it's already lost
because B6 spawn is hanging and then
Knight F4 he picked up the H5 phone and
won the game the other game I had in
mind I was looking it was this end game
with Levon extra Pawn but it's very
difficult to convert four versus three
and The Rook on A4 is extremely active
so Anish didn't have any trouble making
a draw in this game wonderful thank you
far and uh let's take a look at the
standings after 10 rounds of Blitz I
don't think we have any big changes
because the leaders young Christoph Duda
Magnus Carlson and Wesley saw all won
their games exactly only LeBron couldn't
keep pace and MBL because of his defeat
slipped a bit so the top three players
increased their lead with more points
and let's jump to Warsaw and get a
perspective uh firsthand
thanks guys what an incredible round
what an incredible start to this final
championship day here in Poland I have
to say Magnus impressive with the black
pieces out of the opening in a worse
position and manages to just like
accurately outplay mvl that's not an
easy feature but Duda is keeping pace
and that was an absolutely mad game take
a look at this one both of the players
actually had great opportunities in this
one and of course Richie report always
inviting a fight with the benoni why not
right it's Blitz let's take some chances
as Magnus mentioned this is high
variance uh Blitz portion we have to
take chances we have to creating
balances in the position and white
um engages with this h3e3 IDI I kind of
like it don't put the pawn on e4 this is
much more of a strategical approach to
the benoni keep the structure as it is
Knight to EA Knight to D7 the plan for
black is to go F5 G5 perhaps if you
allow me to and try to take advantage of
uh maybe some sort of a space advantage
on the king side
white at the same time wants to go F4
and strike Counter Strike in the center
with E5 at the right moment and this is
exactly what was happening Knight to C7
the Knight is going on the other side to
try to control
I remember the main Square in this
position okay if you manage to do it
it's kind of a race right black wants to
go B5 white wants to go F5 and break
um black structure on the king side this
is what's happening right now and I have
to say black was taking over Queen H4
Knight to E2 white is withdrawing uh his
forces I don't like what Duda is doing
B5 and I was looking at the position
live I thought that ritual report will
uh take him down because it just felt
like his moves were easier B4 B3 perhaps
focus on the weakness on B2 it just felt
like the right moment for Richie to
strike but dude understood that and he
played that five we have to do that as
fast as possible I really like what he
did Bishop takes G6 B4 Knight to E4 and
perhaps B3 Queen to B1 and now Bishop
takes H3 was not the right move Knight
to G6 but it's not easy to calculate was
the right move Knight to F6 it starts
getting very very dangerous but you need
to understand that after Bishop F6 Queen
takes G6 Bishop to G7 Queen to F7
potentially to get the bishop on D7 sure
you're getting to my knight but what I'm
getting to is your Pawn on B2 and once
this Pawn on B3 is Unleashed I'm going
to go B2 B1 and you're going to have
some difficulties in the position by the
way Queen to C4 is the only move wow I
mean it looks really dangerous look at
the position this King on the shades it
looks so exposed absolutely impossible
to find exactly and I have to say the
complications more much more difficult
to handle for a black Bishop takes H3 G
takes H3 and now we get this transition
two pieces for The Rook but once again
it's all about the exposed King on G8
whose King is more explosive I don't
know this this one is covered at least
I feel safe and white but black skin not
so much and it's especially this Knight
on C7 that's not doing a lot it is
defending some important scores E8 and
E6 but outside of that not that much
yeah and now we get this transition and
the Knights are going to do a tremendous
job Jump Around The King Knight to H5
Queen to C2 Knight to F6 and at this
point
beautiful move beautiful opportunity for
uh White to finish the game in style E7
no wow this looks really great yes this
is this is a killing movie so if you
take the queen then I get another
question
exactly if you take the pawn then I have
Queen then I have to check on here okay
j7 this is really a great move I mean
how many seconds you had to fight I'm
not sure not many definitely not many
and he took on H7 which still maintains
some Advantage but definitely loses a
lot of it yes still very difficult to
play for uh for black B2 E7 and then
we've seen the transition into the
bishop and Knight and game which do the
accurately converted what's a game it
was really full of fun absolutely bad
game what game mode did you I'll check
the Derby between two Romanian players
umchenka and Bogdan deck they they had
some kind of fight in the English
opening and I don't know I didn't like
to hear how kale was spent in in the way
that he played too many moves with his
Knight I remember that the opening don't
do that that often yes but okay position
was still good enough I mean but he
decided here to play also very actively
yes when he played yesterday so this
Knight the two was really confusing I
was like looking at the position but you
know sometimes you it's a trick right to
try to surprise your opponent in the in
the in the opening and then his pencils
of time so which was not okay a case in
this situation so bogdam kept really
calm and he took all this material you
know he didn't attention that much what
white was doing it just you know played
King good shade for safety reasons and
then he just simply took the bone look
at this I mean he grabbed one pawn and
asked where is your compensation my
friend yes so and there was not well
kept trying to do something create some
complications but it didn't work out he
lost the second Pawn like that so black
were dominating the whole way and I was
like a very controlled absolutely I mean
look you have really great position just
I mean at the end I would I would like
just to mention that here at this moment
they had really seconds yes like a few
seconds left for both of them seven
seconds
and they were playing this position and
of course Bogdan lost a little bit
control at certain point but but still
he managed at the end to treat kiril and
in this position I guess he lost some
time because I think you're really
awesome time or he resigned at this
moment because Rook F2 is coming and
like you don't really have a defense
like I don't know if you want oh I guess
he just resigned yes maybe yes because
Rook F2 is the final threat right yeah
oh my gosh
it was so so kind of interesting game I
mean people tried still to take his
chances he has a nice nice serious move
yeah yeah I think if you go here I have
this Knight H1 movie
we're just having fun yes yes that this
one looks really nice yes so I walked on
it didn't won his game and um that's it
exciting chess guys from Poland and
still eight rounds to go but I have to
say Magnus with six out of six What's
Happening Here what did he drink after
that round four yesterday to play like
this absolutely uh thrilling around 10.
as again the decisive games are four out
of five eighty percent we came in on the
show saying yesterday it was a 73 score
lots of decisive games that Richie
Rapport game just that you guys would
highlighted we strongly reminded me of
why the benoni is called son of Sorrow
right because oh it was so so so close
let me get in a quick commercial break
we're not going anywhere just want to
say our friends at Q Boutique and what
are they offering well here you go
there's absolutely stunning board makes
the perfect gift to someone else or even
yourself the board is crafted from
Walnut Wood measuring 21 inches by 21
inches for 2.25 inch squares and has
unique rounded Corners displays
laser-cut logos of the world chest Hall
of Fame on the H1 and A8 squares in the
St Louis chess club on the A1 and h8
squares do shop
Q Boutique St louis.com for all your
chest needs and after all of that tell
us about the standings all right we have
Jan Christopher in the lead closely
following Magnus Carlson just half a
point behind it's always Wesley so hot
following Magnus just not that point
behind and the rest of the field is
falling a little bit behind but Livonia
and mvl still have chances to catch up
absolutely yes around 11 is coming up
and let's take a look at the pairings
all right we have Iranian plan
chefchenko
giri against Duda if you could play a
spoiler yeah absolutely Rockford against
MBL
Carlson again so we've got to be our
Marquee matchup game that Carlson versus
so wait cash check against the act and
Anish Gary versus Duda our tournament
leader Duda is going to be our backup
for sure as we'll focus uh on that
Carlson so as we see a shot of the
tournament Hall beautiful beautiful
staging it just feels so good when the
organizers are making uh such a great
show uh I would jump in VAR that I'm
still that game by Magnus for a Blitz
game excuse me but that was really high
quality stuff absolutely very very
impressive Yasser the way he outplayed
mvl from just a much worse end game yeah
they got out of the opening he's in
great shape and Luda really needs to
keep up because it seems like Magnus can
win a lot more games I'm a little bit
disappointed Levon has been struggling
my Peak and he hasn't won a game in the
last few rounds and he has some chances
against Gary he was up upon but he
couldn't convert he definitely needs to
get couple of wins in if he wants to
fight for the very top places but at the
moment We have basically Duda Carlson
Buddha Carlson Wesley and Levon I think
fighting for those top top four places
exactly one of the things uh therefore
and as he jump in on this one too you
see in Blitz the players going on
streaks it can be you know like they go
into tumbler and they lose two on a row
and then they go you know everything
works out really well they score two and
a half out of three and you you see
these mini streaks why yeah I think
because in Leeds it's more about your
Rhythm and your mood that day right so
you can have either a great day or a
horrible day yeah because you don't have
time to recover from one game to another
I think that's the main reason why
and uh
before around
we give Magnus credit for out playing
mvl but let's give kerokan some credit
yeah because you start with such a
position where we're all saying oh white
is much better much better but then you
get counter play and you see what can be
done yeah with the hurricane that B6 B7
B5 very very well time see a couple of
players they like to arrive early they
like I'm one of those players I like
arriving early getting into the Zone uh
feeling the mood of the audience the
noises of the playing Hall then you have
Magnus habitually uh coming late far way
in where you at or early arrival or late
arrival yeah I don't like to arrive late
I like to be there earlier just you know
adjust my pieces fill my score sheet and
just feel like I'm ready to start you
know uh there are a few times I'm late
but then it just takes me a few minutes
to get into the mood to start the game
there he is just
the last Wesley is always early when we
play the U.S Champs yes Kim and I are
always the first to arrive you guys
greet each other hello as we hear the
Public Announcement system and uh yeah
no ceremonial moves for this round let's
let's get it can be stopped E4 D4 C4 B3
uh I was close
B3 and and we saw yesterday Wesley
played at such a nice game against
Magnus and won his game so Magnus wants
his revenge yes
uh D5 no Bishop A3 D5 yeah it might
still come in Knight F6 I'm maybe coming
yeah
um these Queen side fee and shadows
um I know Hikaru has kind of been a a
Trailblazer nepo a little bit bar who
else is is making this such a trend
actually Wesley had a game with the
white pieces here against
and Hikaru has a lot of games to write
in the current position many games he's
the top players and uh I think we're
gonna see some possible transpositions
oftentimes white can also get the move
C4 in at some point here right E7 E6
inviting a tarash tarash type of
position after C5 or D4
I think I've played this few times with
white actually but it always transposes
into something else
by the way just uh we had done this
blitz top ten and you know how many of
our galaxy of stars are in the Bliss top
ten Magnus at number three so I had to
look it up I well if Magnus is number
three I guess hikaru's number one and I
didn't know who number two was ah number
one was Perugia 40 points yeah what was
his rating I think VAR mentioned that
his Blitz trading is 2 900. yeah
yes 2 900 bar you remember when we were
struggling to get to 2600 absolutely
nice not to mention is only 19 years old
don't rub it in nobody's talking
uh Bishop B5 check provoked the night to
come to D7 d7's a lesser Square than the
Knight on C6 but it costs white some
Tempe uh is it Justified VAR uh well
it's a very rare what white is doing
here actually also the move Knight bd7
paper by black normally after the bishop
B5 check they play the move Bishop D7
right but I was still expecting
um after an ibd7 the A6 uh Castle A6
just to capture on D7 try to force let's
say Bishop D7 then you play this
position with the Knight only five you
play uh 95 D3 Knight D2 it's like a
reversed you're playing a reverse nimso
Indian with extra Tempo exactly so
that's what I was expecting but he
Retreat only two now and definitely a
little bit of loss of time but he did
Force the Knight on D7 so it's unclear
whether or not the Knight is well placed
there on the seven square
93 Knight takes C3 Bishop takes C3 I
must say that I find Wesley to be a
natural-born Queen's Gambit accepted
player and after Knight takes E3 he was
inviting Bishop takes C3 B6 and that's
the Queen's Gambit accepted structure
that Wesley is simply very very good and
he feels very comfortable and B7 B6 as
Bishop B2 I feel Black's got to be happy
I mean he's come out of the opening in
decent shape he has his fair share of
the center decent development problems
yeah that's what you want weaknesses
absolutely he's just very comfortable
Queen will go on C7 he can put a bishop
on F6 white is going to have to play the
move C4 to open up that dark Square
Bishop so once that is played you play
Queen C7 then Bishop F6 Rook fd8 I don't
see any any real ideas for Magnus here
to try to create some chances I'm not
gonna uh switch games but I am been told
that uh MV mvl is uh beating up on
somebody richer Rapport oh poor Richie
who just lost that benoni so I think in
this position even Magnus is going to
have trouble
squeezing anything out of this right but
he is inviting Bishop takes F3 maybe
that's uh okay Wesley wasn't ready to
give up his light squared Bishop but I
do find those
um opportunities of uh damaging my
opponent's king sorry I'm concerned that
Magnus didn't play C4 yet can black play
C4 should he include the trade
like because he played C4 right away
okay I was I was wondering if you needed
to get in the trade but yeah C5 C4 on
the board and with this move basically
Wesley is saying strategically speaking
I'm playing against this bishop uh this
um
dark Square Bishop which is kind of
language like Blackmore yeah I don't
want to trade that's the one thing I
will avoid at the moment but wait a
minute
trading and Bishop F6 is a tempo right
that could be actually pretty decent for
black
absolutely and I'm still liking black
even if it it's counterintuitive to make
the trade sorry another alternative
actually Wesley head which was one of
the better moves was just actually just
right here to play the move B5
sacrificed upon on C4 and if you take BC
just play very positional in Knight B6
and this gives them a very strong
position because after cbab he will have
the a file control of the C file after
rook fc8 and also that excellent Square
for the Knight to go to on C4 that's by
being down upon actually black is
slightly better here intriguing in the
current position bar the current
position is just absolutely equal here I
think the Bishops are going to come off
the board and I think after Bishop takes
B2 Queen takes B2 B5 is important move
here to create some control play on the
B file Rook d8 uh but excuse me can I
play The Devil's Advocate and say I
don't know I like my knight I'm not
saying that I'm
overwhelmingly better or anything like
that it just feels like why isn't black
more comfy
he's got the better night I mean Knights
they're temporarily though I can always
play B4 at the right moment okay uh
there is a square D3 that I'm going to
land on
so by the way uh before now would be a
fork right so the move Queen E7 Magnus
is going to play H5 now H5 there fair
and after G5
it could be intriguing uh things are
heating up and give us an estimation of
the current position the current
position is unclear after H5 actually
the best thing black can do is just to
Simply take that pawn
yeah because that's we see that
happening a lot sometimes just we don't
allow the pawn to get on H6 and just
take and it's going to take some time to
get that pawn back you still have some
problems with the B3 Pawn what Magnus
had to do instead of the move H4 if we
go back one move right here he should
have played the move B4 this was an
opportunity for him to remove the Knight
yeah and Knight E4 is the best one 93
doesn't do that much because Queen C3
and only now play the move H4 and I
think this is an improvement over the
game because at least you have some
potential with the C5 at some point here
but now there's no more B4 now no more
because of the 93 thread and H5 there
are not so many pieces here for a white
to attack I mean of course the dream
would be to play sometimes 95 Knight G4
but every time Knight is only five it's
gonna be met by a move Queen F6 pinning
uh the queen and so he did play them and
Wesley needs to take that pawn I think
giving the opportunity for captures and
Wesley didn't hesitate there G6 takes H5
Wesley was very prepared and Magnus
taking a risk because he is jettising
the B3 Pawn
I thought A5 was the intention
absolutely if I was necessary instead of
taking the pawn on B3 only when you take
this Pawn would I take the pawn on B3 uh
that trade really benefited Magnus he
got rid of a weakness while activating
his rook and now Black's pawns are
looking quite weak B6 H5 falling
white should be better yes much better
for white actually close to be winning
wow uh I I
find that kind of a catastrophic wow I
just heard Darius telling me it's plus
five for white
guys Queen G3 95 Rook A7 that Rook is
just incredibly active now and a few
moves ago if you're just doing nothing
on A1 and if you have played the movie
A5 it would have been a long time before
you can activate that rook and I think
the Magnus is just about to win another
game guys
seven in a row that is uh that's a
that's a phenomenal and by the way he's
doing it against the best players in the
world this is Wesley so on the black
side here Wesley you know incredibly
solid
is completely fine it just collapsed in
two moves right Knight G5 setting up
rook A7 I don't know I'm not as good I'm
not a big fan of this one but Rook A7
how am I going to deal with that well I
think there's a move here Queen F5 okay
I beg your pardon why did he play Knight
G5 and not Knight E5 Knight E5 was much
stronger to eliminate that Queen F5 idea
Queen F5 is a defense
but I think nitro5 is good enough yeah
yeah Rook A7 is still is still very
strong here but there is some idea with
Queen G4 and white is still winning
there too why are they still winning
yeah Queen F5 Rook H7 Queen G4 do I have
any Rook D1 check and Knight D2 ideas
six I don't believe that one
I don't believe that one at all
just came over resigns right if you go
King E7 I've got Queen
oh wow that just does it that Rook comes
in okay seven
yeah maybe Rook A7 immediately but Queen
H4 check
where does a king run to King D7 seems
to be and then
King C8 and then another Rook check
that's it and then we shake hands
gleefully yes yeah losing a rook here
basically after Queen H4
and white Canal
okay seven probably yeah yeah and Magnus
has 22 seconds Wesley 30 seconds okay
seven Rook D7 Queen H4
um is this
the best I guess it's
I guess it's it's good but I thought
Queen H4 immediately might have been
just maybe I'm splitting hairs uh what
was the most exact uh VAR uh just Queen
H4 first yes
because then King D7 then you play the
move okay seven if you step on C6 you
lose the Rook on d8 and
right and Magnus is now just chopping
Pawns
good enough but maybe he could have
checked it or won a rook yes that was
the other line was definitely more
winning
we can go into this night in game
because our night will be trapped no we
gotta go check first right so we can uh
but should he exchange I don't think he
should exchange he should keep the coins
right yeah just give it to Queens and
now he's going to pick up all the pawns
H5 H6 and it's it's still winning but
the game goes on when they have 10
seconds Wesley might still pull
something off absolutely no when you
when you got a chance of winning the
game
uh do it uh by the way we are I'm being
told mvl who's uh in the mix let's say
despite his uh uh loss to start the to
start today he's he won
and how is how's Duda doing yeah Duda
and levonne are both in trouble
dude and Lavon
so Levon has really slipped our Wild
Card uh coming into this event who is
leading at one time Wesley just made a
move with one second on the clock but
that's a good move Queenie one check and
Knight D2 and some counter play suddenly
making it's running yeah okay no the
king is absolutely safe it's scary
though with three seconds on the clock
so easy to make a mistake truly that
seven games in a row finishing with a
flare and let's jump to Anish Gary is he
going to play spoiler as he's up against
our tournament leader and Anish is the
most dangerous Pawn
but can do the
finagle he's been amazing can he Finagle
a draw a Perpetual check seven he might
five four I don't know any perpetuals uh
I think white king might be able to hide
he's kind of zigzagging his way up the
board is yeah he's winning no he's
winning now King escapes and he has
resigned and Anita saw litter exactly
which means which means Agnes Carlson is
now and for the first time in the
tournament
in first place he started terribly in
the Rapids uh through I think seven
rounds he took 11 rounds but he's
bleeding now wow okay uh impressive
stuff bar jumping over to you uh tell us
what happened in this round yeah in this
round there were a lot of decisive games
but I think very important was anishkiri
win against the leader Duda and I like
his opening choice and I will show you
the key moment in this game so they have
this position here which it looks like
uh just not not too many pieces on the
board six pounds each but this Rook on
C6 is extremely strong and the problem
in this kind of end games now Rook fc1
is going to come and now you either have
to give up the C file and Rook allow The
Rook C7 attacking on a seven trunk at
some point you're gonna see some h4h5
ideas happening as well like Magnus did
in his game so he ended up actually
forcing The Exchange but after that
we have a very strong pass Pawn on C6
and it's very close two squares away to
advance and actually this is already a
very big advantage and here we see now
he's advancing and and he end up just
simply
and you don't even want to trade Queens
Rooks here because if you trade the
problem is I can go Queen C4 Queen B5
Queen B7 and you're gonna lose this
position so it was a very big advantage
and uh Anish managed to convert this and
actually a big loss for Duda now and
Magnus in Elite
wow and let's take a look at the
standings as another 80 round is under
our belts and Magnus Carlson is leading
the tournament with 19 points Half Point
behind the anchor of Duda and then
following Wesley Seoul levonne aronian
and
mvlon Christa I'm upset with my
colleagues come on guys slow this guy
down I'm doing really really well you
cannot allow 7-0
Warsaw tell us what's going on Magnus is
magnificent
Unstoppable thank you yeah this is just
uh absolutely incredible scenes What's
Happening Here in Poland seven out of
seven in the last seven I mean this is
just ridiculous he's trying to adopt the
field right now adoption is when you win
10 games against a specific opponent in
a row and then you welcome them into the
family but uh this is exactly what
Magnus seems to be trying to do maybe
he's also trying to beat the record of
five years so seven victories in a row
yes yes well he has a good chance to do
so in the next round but let's take a
look at this game very important game
between Richie and Maxim and I have to
say I was absolutely befuddled by uh
this next move by Richie this position
normal trumpovski sure black might have
a slight Edge due to the fact that you
have the two Bishops potential attack on
G5 Rook G8 if the light Square Bishop
opens up then you're in some sort of
trouble now check this next move C takes
D5 inviting the battery after Queen
takes D5 against the pawn on G2 I mean I
understand you get the a hit on the
queen with Knight to F4 you defend the
pawn on G2 but objectively right now
you're just simply losing so out of the
opening just an exchange of Pawns
natural C takes D5 allows black to get a
decisive advantage and uh mvl this is
exactly what he did he never let go of
the advantage transition into a much
better end game
you have the two Bishops you have the
open Center and then uh at this point he
got a pawn this was the critical moment
take on day two take on H2 sure you're
going to take on H7 but in the meantime
while your Rook is not doing anything on
the king side I'm going to open up the
queen side and this is exactly what he
did B5 B4 creating some more weaknesses
the pawn on B2 and then he went on to
convert uh his Advantage he never let go
of his advantage that he got after that
move C takes D5 and took the full point
home Anastasia what game were you
looking I was checking the game between
actually beat level in the first part of
the blitz so I'm sure Levon was really
really motivated to show him uh and to
show him who's who's the boss here right
so it was actually quite a normal
opening and everything went smoothly
until I think this type of points where
kriel actually took the D file and he's
trying actually to use it somehow but
but new that you should do something
quickly so Bishop G5 trying to attack
The Rook so kiril played F6 and then he
played like still F5 you know an
aggressive move invited Bishop back but
then this nice trick with this three yes
so you cannot take the Rook your queen
is hanging at this moment so Queen A2
they continue to play this and here the
critical moment came so rookie three and
it seems like after Queen D1 King H2
black has this nice idea H6 where the
bishop goes yes you can ask this
question and Grill actually bravely
decided to go for this he played H6 but
look what happened yes he allowed Queen
C4 King H7 but now I mean the bishop has
no space where to go so Levon took the
challenge he took on F5 and after that
you know computer says that the position
is much better for black but try to
defend this position it's not that easy
for example the best move with skin H6
and then I invited Green Jade yes let's
go for this it looks and that's why he
didn't play this he took on G6 because
this phone looked very annoying so he
took it and then look what happened I
mean Levon just started to give this
crazy amount of checks and took another
person and now you see it's three points
for the for the piece already position
is unclear King is exposed so Imperial
didn't manage to cope with all this
pressure and it was not so much time on
the clock and at the end we won't manage
to trick him somehow I don't know I mean
there was some there were some
interesting moments like hiruka fate and
then he went to this ending where the
queen was a queen for rook and Bishop
and in the end I mean again crazy amount
of checks and uh I actually was talking
about the results so look what happened
at the end this this Pawn is moving yes
yes so
at the end of the day after all these
checks it turned out that white cannot
do anything with the pawn on it too yes
he found Bishop L6 Queen C4 and rookie
six and after that
um escaped finally with the King and now
it's a question what to do I think at
this moment it's it was White's last
move H4 but here they didn't make it in
time so we will won two games against
Lebanon not bad at all yes not bad at
all guys well before we go on a short
commercial break we will go to a feature
we asked the players how do they like
rapid templates
foreign
man has both rapid and Bliss time
formats which format do you prefer and
which one do you think plays more into
your strengths yeah I like with the most
definitely
but maybe I'm better than rapid I mean
it's difficult to say actually but I
remember when I consider rapid to be my
least favorite uh you know what I'm
control but I was like the most
successful in it in the past I mean I
was like European champion and so on
yeah but basically anything but
classical you know it's very fine it's
just fun you know to play and not
looking back I think like most of the
chess players they love playing Blitz
the most but for some people you know
they love it but they are not as good as
they hope they are I don't know I think
I used to because I focus on the
classical chess much more in the past I
used to be my specialty much more so
because I play so much more Accent on
the preparation
and less on let's say skills in the time
scrambles and all that
um I think there were more rapid
implicit events recently so maybe I got
a little bit a little bit more rounded
but I'm still not a specialist in Rapid
and Blitz but you know I'm having a lot
of fun playing rapidly so and uh
especially play so much online over the
board is different because things are
moving quickly uh it gets a little
physical sometimes so yeah I'm looking
I'm looking forward I always would
prefer a longer format uh so I prefer
classical and then rapid and then Blitz
just because
uh justice about strategy and then
there's a lot more time to think in
Rapids like I used to do very well in
Rapid maybe some time back like I wanted
2018 but we'll see what happens I don't
know it's very hard to say like when I
was younger I used to love 25 10 as if
you know why it was kind of perpetuous
but still super slow but now I'm kind of
old and unpatient and you know I can't
calculate anyway so and all the video
events are with um Mr 15 Boston so it's
kind of strange for me to play any of
these time controls actually but like I
think that five plus two bleach is very
tricky I mean since we are playing three
plus two and three plus two is just just
way quicker so yeah like last year I got
completely smashed in five plus two so
obviously it must be a 25 which I prefer
yeah I don't know which one I will
prefer but I think here
um Blitz might be easier for me because
as I said I'm the last rated then in
Blitz you can expect something more uh
dramatic
so I think it will be more uh random so
it can help me
her to play The Blitz but my friends
tell me that I'm I'm a better rapid
player so I I generally love playing
Short Time Performance because
there's not much preparation and it's
more about coming up with surprising
ideas
um that's a that's a good question
because I used to play Blitz a lot
not not online but it's over the boards
when in Ukraine there was a lot of
tournaments about it I think I played
less Rapids but it's hard to demand what
is my favorite time control because I
think Gucci's player tops player has to
be good in every type
I mean I've learned to like
who appeared more than I used to but in
general I think it's
kind of the ultimate format for the
audience for the players you can just
play a bunch of those don't not get
tired like you can play casually and you
can play it in a more serious and
competitive fashion like we are doing
here and
in general I have this ability to play
fast and you know put a lot of passion
and the clock my opponents offers in
less time
there is to play the the best I am
I've generally done pretty well in in
Rapid in in the grand chess tour
in terms of what I like I probably
likely prefer Blitz but I like both
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back everybody talk about
starting with the bang as here are our
standings after round 11 Blitz World
number one what a comeback and now he's
leading the tournament
with 19 points as he's got a streak of
seven in a row can he make it eight
and close the following young Christoph
Duda with 18 and a half points and
Wesley so is 17 and a half Lavon kind of
fading there as mvl uh scoring uh five
and a half points and let's take a look
at our pairings for round 12. I have
Chef chanko playing void kashak DF
against Carlson what can I say it's the
Magnus Carlson show that will be our
Marquee matchup was Lisa against rapper
an important game mvl Geary and our plan
B Duda versus Iranian because that's
going to be decisive for both players if
somebody can get a win out of that and
look at this line score holy smoked wow
seven in a row I mean
streak in classical chess seven in a row
but the thing is this is Blitz and those
streaks can last and last bar absolutely
absolutely at the moment it seems like
who can stop Magnus who can slow him
down to even for a draw at the moment
because I mean that position against
Wesley looked the safest position you
can have and suddenly like six months
later he was completely busted exactly
it was that Knight takes B3 move that
was really agree just that allowed Rook
takes A6 and
bang you know Magnus is back in it and
we see the players getting ready uh
Richie Rapport I gotta say I mean I
admire him he's really really creative
when he gets his consistency going he's
going to be a world media he really is
but the problem is he does get on the
roller coaster he does overdo it at
times he hasn't learned
and some of these top players judge his
openings as well yeah they say that from
our top players his opening prep is the
least impressive
although fans would disagree I love it
myself absolutely as young Christoph
Duda who had been leading the tournament
I want to say from start to finish
except right now this finish he's in
second
yeah first time I think yeah or maybe
live on past him just level her lead at
some point yeah yesterday I think did do
a flip-flop that is right
as again the players being introduced
and uh every every game is well every
round is full of fun tell us a little
bit about the air Dr Daniel uh he's
having a roller coaster how's he but
he's been he has been
picking VAR I want to say he's he's not
been playing badly he won the first game
against chefchenko right a big win by
the way since Carol's been playing so
well yeah it's definitely extremely
strong Blitz player but again when you
play against the very top players in the
world yeah that that that changes things
so I think definitely he'll be motivated
here he's like let me see if I can stop
Magnus right he wants seven in a row I
don't want to be number eight you know
as Daniel's waiting for Magnus to show
off the board I think we have a 13 year
old ready to play the ceremonial first
move what a thrill at 13 with all of
these galaxy of stars
I go up to Magnus and say yeah he is
oh boy
Carol
okay Maximilian krugulski
he's ready with E4
[Music]
thank you Max 13 years old I don't
remember what I was doing I was trying
to figure out you know how to keep a
score sheet
as we are underway uh Daniel's
polish second try guys second try
the first first time around it wasn't it
wasn't a pretty show all right radislav
really took uh him down now Bishop takes
B5 I'm telling you that's the good move
I think he really wants to win with the
Polish yeah
as Knight F3 C6
um now now according to the theory
according to the engine VAR this is
supposed to be very bad for black why
it's not that bad it's just it's just
showing a little bit of an advantage for
white but it's it's not it's not like
plus one or anything here so he decided
to go Bishop E2
um another alternative was to go [__]
pay for for example just to make sure
you're ready to play the move C4 right
so now E6
um on the board we're expecting castles
uh Andrew was actually recommending just
to take on F3 and just play the move D5
and then he's gonna get the same
position I think he's gonna play D5 now
and uh just just play on the slide
squares now he's done it
uh the trading of the light squared
Bishop but the missing B7 Pawn the
missing E4 Pawn
and the pair of Bishops for a while yeah
if I'm white I want to play C4 I
probably even want to follow it up with
C5 clamping down maybe yeah like if I
play C5 here and I kind of angle for
Queen A4 maybe bishop F4 the combination
of those moves in the meanwhile you've
gotta you've got to go your knight F6
you got to go your Bishop E7 castles uh
I don't see how I can take advantage of
the center with cd5 so I'm thinking I'm
going to clamp down uh what could also
wait since Black's not taken on C4 no
he's definitely so I can wait develop
first and then decide what to do with
the c Pawn
um I'm I'm thinking it's important that
I get in Queen A4 C5 and then on a good
day oops excuse me Knight to D2 to B3 to
A5 so you want to go after cystic spawn
right away right away that was my goal
actually here actually blocker needs to
find a small Bishop B4 I think it's a
very important move to start with
because that's going to allow you a
Tempe only one and then you can can put
a knight on E7 because Knight only seven
is well placed here defending C6 at some
point this will give you an opportunity
to play the move Knight F5 as well yeah
put some pressure on the D4 Pawn so
that's why rookie one maybe it's not the
best move uh the better try would have
been to play Knight C3 okay that
position instead of rookie one yeah and
then to meet the move Bishop D6 with
your suggested movie after C5
Bishop goes back on season and then you
play for the immediate B4 B5 and that
would have been a big Advantage for
white by the way Magnus did not take
advantage of White's move already he did
not play the move Bishop B5 I'm rather
surprised because I don't see a future
for the night this is going to be very
uh unpleasant actually Knight C3 yeah
and now you don't have Bishop D6 the
desired active Square because of C takes
D5 so you play Bishop E7 now and now
very important move is C5 exactly and
again I think what you were just saying
there VAR there was a huge difference if
the Knight had been developed to E7
then from E7 you could jump to the F5
Square pressuring D4 and from E7 you
defenses C5 and C5 and I'm thinking that
uh Daniel he's doing really good uh and
let's not forget yesterday he had very
good chances to beat Magnus
yes that's yeah absolutely exactly in
that streak in fact well as Magnus was
freely confessed he came on with
Christian and he said you know to score
five out of five out of those positions
he could have lost to a niche for
example so that was really something uh
the inclusion of A5 A3 it it has some
Echoes of a Karo Khan gone wrong yes
Bishop's going to come to F4
Pawn's going to go to B4 Pawn's going to
be go to and this is an indication the
move Knight E Knight f60 E8 is an
indication that Magnus accepts that he's
misplaced his Knight the Knight on F6
was not a good Square he's now played
Knight C7 I mean white has such nice
play on The Queen side and black has
zero counter play they just have to
defend for now yeah exactly sometimes
you got to pull in your horns and defend
but how big is it for it's like plus one
and a half here I've owned Bishop F4
only I mean it's really it's even so
it's a huge Advantage yeah but I'm
seeing that that I'm playing with the
queen side and the Trump that you have
the pawn on E6 the extra Center Pawn
you're not playing with the Trump two
Bishops
um the only Contra player block is which
is I think very important to have
something here at least is this bishop
comes to F6 in this position and putting
pressure on the force okay and that
would be his main idea to try to get
some control play but once again guys in
a previous game if you remember against
envy against mvl actually he got Magnus
got a bad position in a round one today
yeah similar bet position but then he
managed to outplay so if the ACT doesn't
do anything and Magnus starts
maneuvering his Knights you know we
could see some chances here because this
bishop on F6 is going to be really
annoying putting pressure on that D4
Pawn which is going to need a constant
defense because it's not protected by a
pawn yeah we know that diac has uh
trouble with the time yeah he always
gets himself in time trouble and right
now he's doing okay is two minutes
Magnus has three but he likes to go into
a think tank and really go down on the
clock so Magnus will definitely take
advantage of that no question about it
and by the way what what isn't
impressive is that while Daniel is
seizing the time trouble uh he also is
playing very very well once he has no
time on his clock and his his opponents
are complaining but they're trying to
exploit the fact that Daniel has no time
on this clock but he actually starts
playing better somehow uh it is a it is
annoying when that happens your your
opponent keeps playing all the good
moves
um think Alexander grishock is a master
of Art
seriously seriously Knight to C7 even
though magnus's position is passive you
could say that Magnus is doing something
and Magnus is aspiring for Bishop F6
Rook E8 and E5 he wants to play with his
trumps which is his majority in the
center So Daniel feeling like he's got
to you know hit the Anvil while it's hot
right uh B5 yeah very low looking big
thing he thought for two and a half
minutes in a Blitz game can't do it just
can't do it that's a terrible time yeah
that's terrible time management uh maybe
he's not going to get punished but I
don't think you can do it at this level
against these guys they're unforgiving
and he played
Magnus responded with
obviously and now he's thinking thinking
some more okay I do like his most Bishop
before okay because maybe Magnus could
have played Knight takes B5
and said okay you have to recapture
Bishop F4 an indication that maybe I'm
ready to play Bishop C7 and Knight B5
with the tempo no just Knight B5 Knight
takes B5 now clearly this Knight belongs
on the C6 square that I don't maybe
let's go right now why not might be it
well he's done it but uh you really have
the feeling that uh you're taking
Liberty and now Quincy 8 and 96 is
coming yeah you've got to bring that
Knight to uh the C6 Square now you have
to be a little bit careful there's no
combination with Bishop D5 and Rook F6
so Queen C8 Bishop D5
Bishop H6 you know G4 score is covered
with by the queen nobody's talking to
you
I was my mate it was a 50 50 shot I go
Queen G4 you don't take it
here we go Magnus has put his Knight on
he's gonna put his Knight on C6 and
maybe the worst has passed I do like
Bishop B2 rerouting the bishop to a
better diagonal now it's stopping Rook
A6 potentially menacing Bishop B5 as
well VAR jump in as Magnus right at the
ship yeah I think he's fine here and I
think with the clock situation I I think
I see some chances for him to win this
game because no if white can exchange
that Livescore Bishop for the Knight he
will be very happy but I think Magnus is
not going to allow that and Bishop B5 is
met by 97 we're gonna see that Knight
jumping in on F5 and if the bishop goes
back to D3 later on he will go back to
C6 so I think it's easier for him
perhaps to play this position and uh the
clock situation I think the egg has like
three seconds and by the way the move G3
does menace a potential for Bishop F4
you couldn't challenge the B line Bishop
53 is the D4 Pawn hanging there is a
bishop H7 at the end of that line so but
uh you you are trading off
um the D4 Pawn for the H7 Pawn I was
thinking that the C5 Palm might be we've
got we've transposed into Bishops of
opposite color uh position I think the
time is going to be the main factor here
because diac is playing on five seconds
yep and Magnus has one minute and 44
seconds so slightly more exposed black
king and by the way the move Bishop E3
could be a little bit uncomfortable I'm
thinking black is beginning to take over
why it's defendant now absolutely the
block is more comfortable at some point
E5 break is going to come into play the
protective pass Pawn on C5 is not
menacing anybody
yeah if it doesn't get too advanced then
yeah I see Bishop E3 in the very near
Bishop pardon me G5 H4 is another idea
yeah weaken the position a little bit
and he's done it Bishop to G5
and Magnus with extra time on the clock
is going to be very happy he's going to
be feeling that this is his game to win
he's doing he's opening up the position
and uh well just a second he's I think
White's position is good but I really
hate his time okay six seconds so how
are we meeting Queen takes D5 check
Bishop E4 Queen back to D6 well I like
my opponent C6
yeah I kind of like your maybe D4 too
though if I could play D5 but I think I
get pinned with Queen E5 oh no I will
try D5 and then I wanted to go E5
oh an E4 you're not afraid of my
connected passers uh you're not afraid
of your vulnerable kid I bet Queen takes
D5 uh Magnus is taking his time why bar
does he have an alternative can't take
on D4 no Queen takes D5 is the the best
move in this place is the best he needs
to take with the queen here yeah but uh
D4 I take on E6 again 25 check
anyway he took with a pawn uh very
unexpected approach Queen E5
uh Queen d8
menacing Bishop F6
I was about to say I I made a loss to
explain magnus's moves because C7 was an
opportunity you know yes you were right
back down plays better when he has no
time right and his opponents could start
to get nervous and Magnus has same time
as back down now
okay and now the pond to five seconds
the pawn on C6 I was about to say I was
gonna go Bishop to A6 to B7 and just
anchor the bishop
um
not playing this for a win right
uh it's good it's a nervy nervy uh
moments here for both players isn't that
D5 Pawn vulnerable
I think it's just you're just equal now
Bishop D4 will be played and then Rook
D1 okay didn't want to take I think
Magnus is still trying to play for a win
but
by the way breaking news uh Lavon who
has been in the Tumblr last few rounds
sorry go ahead one one and we have
another result mvl also won his game
that's a big result
our tournament leader really slipping
and with this move Rook D7 I think that
clinches the draw
right I think
and this is our last game are we seeing
another one of those 80 percent rounds
thanks I believe so there we go finally
someone has stopped Magnus with a draw I
tell you the winning seven in a row it's
hard to make eight uh let's try it we
actually have two draws Right Wesley
also drew his game okay but dude are
losing two in a row whoa well that will
just help Magnus yes
um increasingly by half a point
wow uh there was an opportunity VAR jump
in there was an opportunity here I think
Daniel missed a a great shot right yes
he had he had a chance to play the move
C7 I can uh
uh when the queen was on d8 when the
move Queen d8 was playing let me find
that moment here in this game and uh
yeah I believe that was around move 28.
or 38 I mean 30 yeah right here instead
of the move Rook F1 he played Rook F1
here but if he plays the move C7 now
attacking the queen and the bishop is
hanging here as well right so you have
to either play Queen E7 or queen F6
right and if you play the move Queen F6
or it's it's the same idea you just play
the move Rook B1 and that's going to be
followed by the move Rook B8 so if you
capture D takes E5 and now you need to
stop this by the move Rook
aa8 but then we can play the move Rook
B7 and follow it up with Bishop B5
Bishop D7 the pawn on the seven is
extremely strong so this would have been
a chance for dayak actually to win the
game and uh you know really stop the
stream yeah to have chances and uh he
had a definitely a chance he's playing
well against Magnus right so he had a
chance in the the first game as well
what else happened in the round what uh
stood out uh because we had some other
wins how did Levon beat Duda uh I will
take a look at the other game uh uh
Wesleyan report and I think our friends
gonna look at that game uh Levon versus
do that uh so this game was very
interesting uh it was again a very wild
game as you can see Richie gameplay and
interesting opening so we see some
imbalance in this position two Bishops
two Bishops but the weak Pawn structure
and at some point there was a peace
sacrifice and that right here so there
is an extra Pawn here and if you can
somehow remove these pieces white should
be good here but there is a lot of
control play against the F2 Pawn so
Queen C5 was played and we saw
F4 now trying to remove the Knight if
you go back with the Knight then white
can play the move E5 as well but here
Richie played Queen H4
and now Fe Queen F2 you cannot go back
to H1 Queen G1 made so you have to go
King H3 and now Bishop E3 play this was
the only move actually for Richie he had
to try to exchange this bishop and now
he has a lot of Contra plays so after
the move Bishop B3 we saw D6
C2
and the exchange and now picking up on
C1 eventually Bishop D3 but it's
opposite coloring games so the game
ended in a draw guys
wow uh and another eventful round and
let's take a look at our standings
uh it's been great stuff yes and Magnus
increased his lead because uh dude I
lost his game so we have Magnus Carlson
in the first place do the second Wesley
third and Lavon and mvl Sharon fourth
wow uh great stuff uh to 12 rounds full
point ahead I know I know well that's
what winning seven in a row could do for
you and let's jump over to what Warsaw
to get the view
from Poland
well Duda is definitely not finding his
form in today's rounds and I have to say
he's getting very decent positions with
the trumpovsky in this game he tried to
emulate Richie report it didn't work for
Richie unfortunately for Duda it didn't
work for him either C5 Bishop takes G6
Bishop takes F6 and G takes F6 and this
is probably one of the most aggressive
way that you can play with the black
pieces your structure is going to be
slightly destroyed nevertheless at least
you got the two Bishops and right now
you're going to try to open the center
and get to the G2 Pawn potentially but
let's take a look at what happened take
on C5 Knight C6 Knight F3 now we see
this exchanges C3 so that white doesn't
recapture uh the pawn the last Pawn with
the Knight Knight to C4 and then you're
going to have a lot of activity over the
C and D files so that's why black gives
the pawn but gives it on his terms with
the move C3 and now we have this
position and I have to say dude I was
playing well Duda was gaining the
advantage in this game Queen to B5 Queen
to E2 slowly slowly poking at a black
structure especially this Pawn on F5 and
take a look at this he did yes he did he
did still very complicated because black
also took the pawn on A2 so in any sort
of end game that a pawn is going to go
down the board extremely quickly A5 a4n
is going to be supported by the Bishops
as well Queen 2 G2 this was the critical
moment Rook to F1 take take it seems
like I'm getting a lot of pieces around
the king look at my Knights look at my
Rook ready to jump to H4 it's not scared
exactly and at this point this was the
critical move Rook to H4 try to increase
the pressure on the H5
maybe sometimes
for example that's a very good
sorry if Rook GA doesn't work actually
but Queen has three years
we stumbled into success yeah very good
very good we found it
so Rook to H4 was the key what I think
he missed is that after Queen to G6 and
by the way this is extremely difficult
to understand Rook to H6 seems like a
natural move right Bishop takes E3 wow
and that's unfortunately losing for
white because now I'm going to capture
The Rook on H6 so guess what the move is
in this position Rook to H6 is a move
that we need to play next one yes
prophylaxis I mean this is just an
incredible you cannot find this with
just a few seconds on the clock no way
you need to spend at least 20 minutes to
try to understand
he did not do that he played Knight to
D4 and unfortunately for him this seems
to be giving black some serious chances
because now my knight is close to my
king finally I can get the Knight on G6
and that's going to allow me to defend
my position still I mean it looks so
scary and by the way he did have this
winning move Knight takes F7 Rook takes
F7 Rook takes F7 Knight takes H4 and
guess what right now Rook against F7
King takes A7 Knight to God and I'm
taking the queen wow this is like a
maddening stuff uh happening of course
you're not going to be by the way at
this point you have three seconds okay
on this clock so understandable find it
it would be really understandable he he
brought his pieces next to his King
unfortunately does not enough and it
takes away from your defensive resources
and we can see that's exactly what
happened the transition into the end
game yeah and the apostles
look at him going and you cannot catch
that pawn that's game over dude that
loses two in a row what an adventure are
you
I'm always looking forward for these
games especially after the first round
of Blitz I mean when you remember it was
so crazy so this one was also quite fun
I wanted to show a couple of moments
like I think somewhere here around here
after moved to six it was very funny
moment maybe white could play this King
Joseph and I just said look king of fate
and then go back you know proposing I
could take the Pips yes and then just
Bishop back for believe it or not but
the computer was happy about this
position for white I mean like has a lot
of initiative and this king is exposed
and probably maximum you know could gain
something here but what happened after
we just continued the game normal normal
position I would like to show maybe even
the critical moment I was somewhere here
where Anish pushed this F4 so D6 you
know black pawn D6 looks very white
spawn looks very dangerous of course and
it looks the position was getting worse
but here
um initials maybe the last
the things like now age six and the
picture before there is this three
Bishop C8 and it's still not over this
looks nice but look rookie eight after
luruka for you I mean if I mean you
cannot really find out this yeah
Bishop F3 and it's complete like D7
maybe is also threat so this position
could be really crazy but at the end of
the day he didn't play this move he
actually just moved um moved his rook
and after that it was after Rook D7
white simply took Pawn on F4 and then
Maxi managed to convert it easily well
what an incredible game let's take a
look at the standings as we go into the
third round of the day yeah but do you
remember also we wanted to speak about
my mistake yes oh my goodness Magnus
that's a massive score nine and a half
wow and right now topping the
leaderboard with a one point Advantage
you actually stopped to the 18 and a
half Wesley so closely behind and Magnus
is coming off a big day in soccer not in
chess yes it was a really great evening
yesterday I mean he played uh not only
him of course it was a team Grandmaster
Steve including Christian as well and uh
we all went to my partner yes of course
and it was important part two goals and
Magnus also scored two at the end it was
7-3 in favor of grand Masters look the
August is in a good shape yes yes and I
think he really had lots of fun and
everybody enjoyed this match and of
course today maybe he feels full of
energy wow yes now you could see the
goal and I managed to score once yes yes
yes look at you he didn't touch my
second goal yeah yeah it was not there
anymore but look I mean I mean it's a
really great attitude like you go you
play football it helps you you to feel
better relaxed and then you come back
yes and this is exactly what Magnus said
also as we did our interview and he was
leaving I'll see you on the pitch and
it's going to be good to release some
intention exactly and then you come back
and you just win few more games that's
it this is a recipe why not we're going
to go on a short commercial break and we
will be back shortly with round four
foreign
[Music]
sponsored by St Louis chess club and the
World Chess Hall of Fame for
ticketsmuni.org
the St Louis chess club is the Premier
chess facility in the United States we
bring the educational benefits of Chess
to thousands of students across the St
Louis area we also promote Chess at the
highest levels hosting all levels of the
U.S championships as well as high
profile tournaments that attract the
world's best players become a member and
enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit
stlouischesclub.org to claim your
membership today
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back everyone as the blitz is
definitely living up to his name and
reputation we've been enjoying ourselves
standings please after round 12. we have
world number one lead in the tournament
Magnus Carlson in the lead followed by
Young Christoph Duda Wesley Sohan a
fourth place sharing Livonia ronian and
mvl you can tell Blitz scores who's
doing what to whom Miss Magnus is that
definitely enjoying himself and what
about our parents for round 13. let's
take a look we have Duda against
chefchenko aronian MBL yes
Gary Wesley
Rapport diac and the key matchup Carlson
against white Tasha absolutely
and with Lavon and MBL as being the
backup game and great stuff but somebody
finally stopped magma as far I it was
close there we almost saw eight in a row
absolutely yeah
um you know play play well and he he
didn't need much time here like three
seconds he had three seconds and he just
played some good moves and uh held
Magnus so he stopped the streak and the
question is if Magnus can make another
streak now six games to go I just have
to interrupt and say I look at Richard's
Richie he's not his posture they're uh
tell me what he's thinking what's going
on right here I want to be there he
remembers all the missed opportunities
wow in this in this event starting from
Rapid and probably Blitz now
yeah I think he lost two or three games
in a row so of course not feeling great
not doing it as uh well one player who
is feeling it Magnus Carlson redislav
has kind of gone into a tumbler as well
of Richie's been suffering so is that
it's like yeah he started very well in
the rapid but the blitz has not been
going so well for him
now tell me once again if we do get to a
playoffs let's let's take our viewers
through the scenarios if there are two
players tied for the first there'll be
two game rapid match if there are three
plus players tied there'll be Blitz
round robin five plus three and if
they're still tied then we're gonna have
an Armageddon oh that would be fun as
round 13 underway and we're going to be
following the game between Magnus and
radislav and by the way old Bob vinic
idea in the English early D4 Bishop B4
is always considered The go-to Equalizer
and the G2 G3 old games of Bob vinig I
played this myself on a couple of
occasions I I actually beat Luke
vanvelli in an Olympiad where it is
white but I'm not a big believer in this
line VAR
uh there there are some games here I see
some kayaking game actually your game
against Luke Van Valley from 1998
Olympia oh yeah right yes
um about 38 games played in this
position 95 is the main move putting
pressure on C4 here now Bishop takes C3
check but Knight E5 okay Bishop C3 check
is the second most popular move as well
right but 95 played slightly more and
here white can play Queen B3 and also
you can also Castle just sacrifice the
C4 Pawn as well but Queen B3 is the main
move here yep and how would things go
after Queen D3 after Queen B3 Bishop C5
maybe bishop C5 yes
and normally uh there are a few
different moves here you can play the
move Knight C2 then Bishop E3 or you can
play the move Bishop E3 immediately here
as well after Knight C2 the queen really
kind of looks like a little bit yeah
uh ideas about vinic that I remember
were include sacrificing the pawn on C4
uh castles and what's the composition
for it well the two Bishops and
oftentimes you're playing for Bishop G5
and uh the crazy part is okay here we
see Queen B3 but with the move Bishop G5
sometimes this pin H6 Bishop H4 G5 could
actually allow Knight F5 and there's a
serious attack going on yes and we do
see the line with Knight C2
statistically speaking VAR tell our
audience how white does when he gets
himself into this position only three
games in a database and all three of
them ended in a draw
simple yeah three games three drums now
the move Knight A4 on the other hand
hunting down the two Bishops if
if you just allow me to take and play
Queen C3 life is good for for white
he'll have the two Bishops and a better
structure what is black going to do to
stop that I think I have to allow you
the exchange but I'm gonna do it on B6
on your turn yes you're gonna drop the
bishop back so that you can play a takes
B6 uh at least in this case your Rook is
a little bit active you are
potentially threatening Bishop E6 so
white makes room
uh right I gotta borrow from Jacques
for my B Pawn uh rookie eight castles
are we still in theory bar no we're not
in theory the end here actually uh White
wants to play the move B3 yep that's why
very important to put the queen on City
so you can play B3 and put the bishop on
B2 here white has a slightly better
position because you have a little bit
more control of the center and
definitely the pair of the bishop this
could get really unpleasant for white
ashek if Magnus solidifies the position
yeah when I see this move Queen C8 I do
I was about to say I do want to move my
Rook to maintain the advantage of the
two Bishops he played very quickly
Bishop G5 did Magnus and Magnus is
saying look I am prepared to give back
the two Bishops with Bishop takes F6 but
at the cost of really severely damaging
your structure serving us here I was
just thinking where is the Black Knight
going to go because if it goes to D7
then Quincy not happy setup doesn't make
sense and also after 97 is there a four
out five trap in the bishop yes I think
so very very much so F4 F5 I was
thinking F to D7 that's what I was
looking at yes
exactly exactly in this position
interview with a Tempo yes yeah and then
F4 and F5 and black is definitely crying
Knight to D7 well this does invite
Knight to D4 and give me another Bishop
oh two Bishop this is very passive for
witashek a very passive two Bishops
better control of Center I think it's
just going to be very easy play here for
Magnus here he can take only six now
yeah and get the two Bishops and uh
Knight G5 for can I take on G5 option 96
so you don't get the two Bishops and
then I would recapture
but the Knight on G5 is very pretty yeah
and it's just not easy to get rid of uh
Bishop just dropped back to E3 sorry but
this opening in my view is white all the
way uh this is just uh uh he's he he's
achieved uh everything you you want here
I would find myself attracted to F3 and
Bishop F2 playing for E4 if if I get an
F3 and you put your Bishop back
and I get an E4 the bishop on H5 is kind
of just kind of nudged off the board if
you will yeah I do find myself attracted
very much to magnus's position yeah if
the English guaranteed positions like
this
sign me up I I completely agree uh
yeah
yeah a lot of Bishop moves here by boy
tashek in this game yeah and Bishop went
back to H5 rookie one just defending E2
prepping Bishop F2 and again put the
pawn on e4 and ask the bishop how do you
like it you're not going to be happy
so can black
be aspire to play D5 I was going to say
D5 to maybe right but no this is this is
great uh oftentimes in these structures
where you want to maintain the pawn on
F3 and E4 the bishop on G2 is not happy
but now I can sneak my Bishop out to H3
and I can be on a very active diagonal
so I like everything but how big an
advantage is it ever it's more than plus
two more than that's huge yeah black is
just very passive here A4 is a good move
just to you know make sure now that we
can move the Rook without the pawn
hanging and uh you know just to control
the B5 square and you know full control
of the centers pair of the Bishops
yeah very very big Advantage here
exactly uh in these positions I
definitely do not want to allow the
trade of nights I like the idea of
bringing the knights to the D5 Square he
put the Knight on B5 which is okay
because it just keeps the queen a little
bit honest personally 92 Knight F4
Knight D5 I love the night on the card
still get to D5 via C3 right but then I
have to move my queen guess what uh he's
uh radislav is going to give white
another opportunity to get the Knight to
D5 because again I'm really chasing that
night yeah and I don't think uh White
should allow it
when you have a space advantage in the
center like we're seeing keep the pieces
on the board let your opponent enjoy his
cramped position don't help him by a
move like Knight takes C6 is what we
would call a strategic mistake you're
just helping your opponent get rid of
passive I think he's gonna choose your
line now maybe Knight E2 Knight F4 it's
looking great it does these guys are
really really good that's the test right
now let's see how good he is
and wow breaking news there's a quick
resignation by Levon against mvl
apparently he had he blundered
whoa whoa uh for mvl that is a huge win
and for Lavon once again I mean our uh
while one of our Wild Card players Lavon
aronian at one time led the tournament
and he slipped very badly in the last
round he defeated Duda too
did yeah really a really bad blunder by
levonne actually
by the way the move Knight A5
invited before oh there was Knight takes
A4 some tricky trickies but uh oh those
nights yeah they're living precariously
I just want to say uh not too sure but
by the way the night is finally
eyeballing uh that beautiful anchor
Square uh D5 uh wonderful interesting in
this position black can't do anything
but just move the Knight back and forth
exactly and I hear uh I I just heard
that Duda is also winning his game
okay keeping the pressure
and Rapport just beat diac okay so
Richie uh still on that roller coaster
uh mixing uh too many wins and too many
losses too
97 and by the way Knight F4 look at that
it's fine he didn't play Bishop H3 I
could have I would have lost a big wager
there uh three one of the things that
grand Masters just absolutely love is
developing their pieces with a Tempo and
I Wild Horses wouldn't have stopped me
from playing Bishop H3 also by the way
Knight H5 is a very disruptive move
when the night was on F4 and I mean
there was a
too many good moves for white in this
position right
right
and now can I even play
oh A5 beautiful because if you take what
the night I finally have that fork with
the pond before
ah I was looking at Bishop C5 and Knight
F6 but you're absolutely right
um
B4 no but and if you take what upon that
yeah Bishop C5 Knight F6 uh this was a
massive really strong move for I think
Magnus is just cementing his plus two
Advantage with this last move eight four
eight five it's actually almost plus
four now
he's allowing Knight F6 check at
Discovery and the king is going to be
vulnerable as well
so we have what's the material imbalance
Queen for rook and the Knight minor
piece but also the white also has an
extra Pawn I believe yes
yeah but it's the damaged King that
really stands out uh for me uh F4 uh
eyeballing E5 on that b-shabangita is
going to become a monster
sure is uh the odds are high
Rook Knight C2 doing his best to be
irritating
Rook C1
also attracted to E5 81 takes a I take
the Rook yeah there he goes E5
immediately
um oh he can still play rookie 2 here
rookie too because there is a queen G4
check to pick that pick up the Rook uh
well spotted by the way rookie rookie
two is the best yeah
tomb of tactics I can do
and uh I have a feeling that Magnus is
feeling it I mean his last few moves he
just
blitzed them out like this is all the
ABCs of the position
and queen takes H6 and that's what I was
afraid of that Black's King is going to
come under a threat G-Force F5 and
Magnus Duda has won his game and
Wesley's winning his and magnus's
winning hits and he he just did and he
just did so let's quickly jump to
Wesley's game that's the only one still
going on it's Anish Gary my pick night
and game and Wesley's at the pawn with
two connected passers should be an easy
win but still have to be a little
careful night endings can be if you lose
one of them right that's it
night endings can be tricky and for the
moment they kind of stuck the passers uh
they're not going anywhere
that okay but white has no counter play
so
94.95 stop Knight D4 I was afraid of the
move 1940. I can't just keep improving
this position no rush
foreign
[Music]
night to
some trickies as Anisha and he's not
giving up on this one VAR
yes I think just he needs to take on a
G4 here okay oh he took with the Knights
age four oh I have missed that as well
Knight to that's impressive with no time
on the clock he just goes for this is it
winning yeah I think the Knight is stuck
and Black's King makes a triumphant uh
March
and no time for Anish this is the best
way to win the night end game sacrifice
the night
he did it wrongly he didn't need to go
why kingy two and then just take on F4
I have so many passports I can push any
of them
it's true you have a Pawn on H3 that's a
yeah I think this is it one of those
guys is going to win oh Knight F5
threatening Knight G3 but then the king
can come back to D1 uh great stuff and
again single draw the number of decisive
games as we started our show 73 and day
one of the Blitz and we're matching that
after a five for five uh VAR uh
another eventful round what uh what
happened absolutely a lot of interesting
games the game that caught my eye was
the dude that game now he's back he won
a very strong attacking game here I want
to show you the key moment of this game
against chefchenko so as we can see he
already has a very big Advantage the
bishop Bishop is very strong only six
and now he he played the move H4 trying
to open up the position completely and
here there is some pressure coming on
this diagonal so do that played the move
D5 just to Simply shut down everything
here and now Queen E8 played as we can
see complete domination here the bishop
is blocked on B7 there is no counter
play on a g file and now there is a
black is also losing material here so
Knight takes C3
takes on H6 and now you're losing more
material now the Knight is hanging and
he end up just simply converting this
into a win so it's good to see do that
win a game now he's back in the mix so I
think we'll see some exciting a few more
games in this event fantastic uh nice
stuff as I'm looking at the round 14 but
first our standings uh
Magnus still leading with a full point
ahead uh young Christoph dudas in the
second place and Wesley's in the clear
third and now mvl is in the clear fourth
passing live on Iranian because he just
defeated Levon exactly as we were
getting ready for round 14 Blitz uh we
but we'll hold off on the parents let's
just jump to Warsaw and get the view
from the plane Hall
thank you
a lot of Fighting Chess in this one guys
I have to say and I was mightily
impressed with this game I'm not going
to uh I'm going to keep it short because
this one is very very intriguing but the
final position is absolutely amazing
take a look at this so Knight to F6 we
have this typical position in which
white has a couple of options you can go
short Castle or you can do what Richard
did and probably Richie will always do
in this type of situations go for H4 and
the attack against the key H4 isn't like
discuss all of this thing shorts no why
would we do that of course let's go for
the kill Bishop takes F6 H5 wow and an
exchange sacrifice it's not good forget
about it objectively is not great but
it's Blitz
and he's playing also against Bogdan who
we know is a time travel addict Queen to
C8 Queen to D3 uh Queen to G4 Knight to
E2 I really like this swarming nights
around the king and the Rook is going to
follow as well Rook which one is coming
for sure so H4 was a big mistake at this
point you had to go Queen to G6 in fight
the move Knight to F5 and after King to
f8 you have ideas of Rook to E4 you have
this pin on the Knight on F5 already
established unfortunately for him
he played the wrong move yeah
it makes a lot of sense but it makes a
lot of sense Knight F5 take a look at
this Knight to E5 okay okay and queen to
G5
surprise your queen is completely
trapped no it's over if you go to G8 97
is a check shot oh my gosh wow
absolutely amazing position Queen H5 now
1977 wow I think this one is like
Billiards and I take your queen as well
thank you very much good luck look at
the fantastic job this time this is nice
this is nice yes even your nights are
when the openness nights come to close
yes it can go foreign
against Samuel it was actually a big
drama in this in this one because the
game was just normal one you know this
kind of Sicilian Bishop went into then
moved to C4 after E5 because it has
better Square here so I mean they were
just exchanging pieces it seemed to be
that it would be just this kind of
Grandmaster draw right at the end of the
day like you can see that okay I'm well
managed to push F5 but again things were
not bad for white as well everything
everything that was fantastic yes so and
here it would be case Rook F2 what would
you play normally I would probably take
Rook F2 maybe I don't know a couple of
checks so it's balanced position but
here we won't play this move King Javon
and the position went from 0 to -20
immediately yes so absolutely winning
after that but let's try to find the
movement seven bro Christianity seven
and the game is over yes after queen of
seven white has no defense yes you just
resigned because look I mean of course
if you take one of two it's a Checkmate
this one which was started when we were
kids and then I mean but there is no
move there's only if you run if what if
you run away yes so now I think you can
just go Queen D5 and this is the idea oh
my gosh why you want to put the queen
excuse me because now you can attack the
pawn on G2 from the diagonal yes and
there is no way to defend it yes E4 but
then Queen takes D3 now I'm again yes
terrible so here we won't just simply
resent and this was very dramatic again
because now
um actually Maxine took his place yeah
yes so incredible
I mean they're getting of course more
tires after five days of playing and I'm
gonna tell you something in the plane
area it became really calm you know in
this rest area they are not charging
that much as before the energy yes
because you know it's last rounds
everything will be decided right now in
these last ones Championship rounds are
about to unfold we're going to go on a
short commercial break and we'll be back
shortly foreign
[Music]
for the first time since 2020 the
world's best female chess players
converged in the chess capital of
America Saint Louis Missouri for the
Third Edition of the Karens cup
beginning June 3rd players will compete
for a 180 000 prize fund
this tournament features 10 of the top
female chess players in the world
including returning Champion humpy
koneru along with top-rated American
Irina Crush
it's one of the most decisive classical
tournaments in chess that you won't want
to miss catch all the action on the
Saint Louis chess club YouTube and
twitch channels
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
thank you thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
okay
hello everyone and welcome back to our
live coverage of the superbed rapid and
Blitz in Poland these are our standings
after 13 Rounds of Blitz we have Madness
Carlson leading the tournament with 20
and a half points young Christoph Tuda
just a point behind and Wesley's showing
the clear third with MPL in the fourth
place trying to catch up absolutely I
still feel like everything to play for
as we take a look at our pairings for
round 14.
Magnus Carlson very exciting game bad
there I think we've got it
call that as our uh main match yeah boy
tashek against rapper okay against giri
and our backup match Wesley against
Iranian and what about him
okay so we're gonna go with the top one
and maybe MBL do this as Plan B and boy
these are exciting game exciting
pairings and if you like decisive chess
well welcome
today we've had 80 of decisive games wow
this is so rare I know the players are
swinging for the fence as far but I feel
like it's a combination of more blunders
than anything too
yes we're definitely some blunders but
it's amazing to see Magnus he scored
eight and a half out of the last nine
games guys seriously seriously and
for Lavon
that last game against mvl that was
devastating he just gave the game away
with one move absolutely he had a better
position up a pawn and just one blunder
and then a huge blundered King G1 just
gave the win to mvl and this was a
player he was tied with for the third
place so now everybody else with the one
point lead and we've seen this prize
fund so we know that you know a half a
point can really cost you ten thousand
Levon finished uh rapid in the second
place and then he was doing so well in
the blitz that he took first for a very
brief moment and then he just all fell
apart we have a couple of losses in a
row and
if you take madness's fantastic Fortune
what you were just saying Dave are eight
and a half out of nine or whatever it's
been uh and contrast and compare the
last eight rounds of LeBron
that's the flip side of that coin as we
can see some players start really well
and some players like Magnus finish
really well
and two of the players still in the hunt
they're mvl on the left Duda who has
been leading for much of the competition
finding himself looking at a blazing
Magnus Carlson somebody please take care
of Magnus who does asking Carol are you
the one
we'll see that's with E4
nice
and Magnus adjusting all the pieces
of Sicilian uh especially he plays a
couple of Sicilian games already right
but a Lapin no svenikov for you no
russellimos a Lapin c2c3
um
and notice how his Knights are always
facing each other right I mean because
Heroes Knights are straight yes I've
always liked the the forward-looking
knights and Bobby and Gary both like the
knights facing one another c2c3 uh D7 D5
as well as Knight F6 are the main uh
moves D7 D5 I remember Gary Kasparov
versus deep Jr the first match a very
exciting match that Gary won people
forget the match that Gary won they
always remember that match that Gary
lost to Deep Blue uh but the first match
took place in Philadelphia
uh Maurice Ashley and I were calling
that action that was great stuff as
Knight C4 what's the statistics of this
uh position tell us uh VAR a lot of
games you know database Yasser over 100
games played and now Knight C6 is the
natural move and now Bishop E3 can be
played
against that move very interesting move
is Knight D5 try to attack the bishop
only three right
and if you take let's say on C5 Knight
takes C3 and that will allow you to
recapture the pawn back with the bishop
on C5 uh media 95 I was just gonna say
it's curious why is Knight going to C4
so early when we haven't even developed
the king side and Castle yet and there's
the answer why not so white knight wants
to grab the center of my id5 I always
thought this was premature however I
thought that after Knight takes E5
Knight takes E5 A7 A6 the problem with
the Knight being on E5 is basically the
D4 Pawn like I play A6 and I don't know
if you're happy allowing the isolated
Queen Pawn when I've got Bishop B4 check
Queen A4 check Bishop D7 unhappy go
ahead win the two Bishops but I don't
think that that's serious again
statistically speaking VAR uh break it
down for our viewers uh how are the
players doing once they reach this
position actually a lot of a lot of
moves like a lot of games in this still
we transpose to like a French Rubenstein
organization and there was a game played
by Magnus with the white pieces against
Arjun arigaisi from 2022 so he's
definitely familiar with this position
because he now he played from both
colors now he's playing for black but he
hit a game with the white pieces as well
right and looks like I played this
position as well
I noticed you didn't quote your own
games uh excessive
modesty no no it was it's a
transposition I hit a game against
rustan panamario in this line he then
they didn't draw in a world cup but uh
it's just it was a French defense but
this was a lap in just a transposition
that game
it was a drug I think that game was a
draw uh you let him off the hook did you
have some excited moves Bishop B5 uh
taking advantage of the pin and magnus's
uh this is following bars game yeah it's
all Theory yeah no kidding okay VAR
you're the you're the resident expert on
this one what what's going on and
what's going on I have to check this
game was played in 2009 yes it's been a
little while it's not fresh yeah no no
not as fresh but I remember analyzing
before that tournament and I made a
relatively easy draw in that game but I
think now we are deviating from my game
and so we're gonna see uh an end game
right where I think black should be okay
here after exchanging on D4 F6 makes
sense because you want to make sure you
can develop your Bishop without dropping
the pawn on G7 and maybe uh depends on
where you go with your king I thought if
you go long I would go long but if
you're going to put your King on E2
maybe I'm just gonna stick my king on F7
Play Bishop E7 and Rook d8
um
this is very very technical and I'm sure
Magnus is doing absolutely fine as
there's some other game where that where
maybe somewhere
uh let's do it let's go to that game I
just heard of the mvl's already doing
very well he has a nice advantage okay
uh but it's it's chaotic right I mean
because there is an open G file I've
castled Rook is coming to E1 doubling
the Rooks a little weakness over here on
H5 can always be tenderized by Bishop to
D1 I'm liking white I just don't know by
how much how about you bar jump in on
this one for us uh what did the engines
think of whoa whoa whoa whoa where Rook
takes E7 yet this is just winning for
white actually whoa
and do that again pushing this a partner
oftentimes we see him do that guys he
plays A5 A4 where you know it worked out
in some of the games but in this one I
don't think it's going to work out
Bishop D1 now Bishop D1 is just killing
right
yeah
six here after Bishop D1 wow okay this
could be huge as mvl research surging
that would be his third win in a row I
think
okay uh by the way you got a nice little
Nuance there Bishop D1 tickling the pawn
provoking the move Bishop G6 and only
now Bishop C2 so that brilliant
technique yeah Bishop takes E2 Queen
takes E2 and I'm about to play a visit
on H seven uh the vulnerability of of
Black's King is what it's all about here
VAR yeah I'm getting a feeling guys that
do that is just playing very
optimistically at times you know like
it's just forgetting about the
principles or just pushing the pawns
forward here but definitely this is
going to backfire just way too many
weaknesses in the position now H5 A4 and
the King position as well so uh this is
just I think uh just simply winning now
for NBL Amen to that this is looks
terrible yeah
after losing to Carlson and Via lot won
three games in a row and this would be
his fourth that is always so impressive
to me when you've had a terrible setback
losing to Magnus Carlson huge huge game
for MBL and how does he respond wins
three in a row I mean that is just like
wow uh you know hats off Duda shaking
his head definitely unhappy just played
the move f
five making his Bishop really really an
ugly an ugly uh piece for sure but he he
does unleash the threat of Bishop takes
H4 which did Force mvl to take a time
out there now I'm thinking Bishop E5
followed by Rook F3 and let's gang up on
this Pawn on F5 if I go Rook to F3 by
the way I'm Queen's coming yeah yeah
yeah I'm sneaky sneaky thinking uh Queen
H6 uh dude that looks looks toasted here
black king needs to run to H7 maybe
it'll be safer there so King G8 Rook F3
King H7
get on your sneakers and hope huh no let
your queen on H6 because that would be
game over agreed agreed you know what I
I first of all I think your defensive
idea is almost forced but I'm seeing
Rook F3 Rook F4
I mean I'm just gonna pile up
the whole team on F5
it looks nice and
I mean everybody I can do about it yeah
everybody is going to be eyeballing the
F5 Pawn here
in there mvl goes and King H7
Queen F4 very very direct give me the
pawn
and where's the
follow-up it's almost like you want to
G4 crushing guys G4
how is G4 oh okay nice
okay it's a little bit hidden but by the
way G4 it still would work right now
Queen F3 uh a little wobble going on
here for mvo
a little wobble but he's still Bishop
F4 and rookie E6 absolutely that's the
winning pawn bishop going to have four
comes to E6 I will not criticize King H2
at all often times you want to get off
the first rank so there's no background
check
and by the way uh breaking news we do
have a draw between Wesley and live one
nice yeah that was a very solid game and
uh just I think both players need to
just chill a little bit take a break
yeah yeah uh Bishop F4 Rook E6 once
again on White's agenda and mvl says
yeah he just keeps improving his
position maneuvering and yeah
very hard to defend this with black no
no time forever for F5 F4 that would
hang the pawn on H5 Rook E7 uh that
feels like the Bell is beginning to toll
here how big is the advantage bar
uh it's it's completely winning it's
like plus five here all right plus five
now Rook one E6 would be a good option
just get the Rook The Rook only one into
the game
am I blundering the D4 Pawn though I
mean I like this move Queen F4 just
I mean The Rook is not going away Rook
E6 is still massive right massive
advantage
also looks good Queen D6 that looks nice
yeah that looks good there's a problem
here
too many good moves right sometimes all
you need is a good problem but yeah yeah
most of the time you just need one
really good move per position Rook takes
E7 Rook takes E7 and now taken with any
piece oh no dude that just blundered the
bishop on oh he does have a trick E1 is
unprotected so he doesn't lose material
okay six
Bishop F7
rookie six Bishop F7
Bishop takes F5 I've been looking for
that opportunity for some time rookie 6
looks like a crushing move times uh Duda
has four seconds and mvl has a little
bit more than one minute again I mean I
just don't understand how you can
mismanage your time to be that far
behind your opponent rookie six
and Rook E3 Bishop takes D4
a lot of exchanges and at the end mvl is
at the peace remember what we were
saying there about the king being on H2
versus G1 well look how that has
benefited White Queen takes F5 check and
we also repeats for two pawns there goes
one of them well it was three pawns now
it's two there is another one
keep going it's just an extra piece now
okay and the King can go to age three
words very very nice and he can just
push the H Pawn yes
this should be an easy
Let's uh let's finish with this game
because there's no way that that that a
dude has been saving a lot of bad
positions there's no way for sure let's
jump back to Carol and Magnus because a
rook component game and
uh is Magnus got a a pawn breakthrough
of our yeah I think he's just gonna win
the G2 Pawn
he will win the G2 partner G3 punished
just too far Advanced yes sir too fast
just take this take that
I can't he outplayed in a completely
equal position it was two Rooks and a
bishop when we left this
he does that to the best of him he's too
good in the end games by the way King F4
to G3 a little bit surprising to my mind
um Magnus could have just captured on B2
and
oh I just heard that he blew it that
this is a drove now
wow okay G2 I don't know if it's an easy
one when B4 was played guys he could
have just played the move Rook F4
protecting H4 and then go King F2 now
he's winning again because he just
picked up all the pawns and
uh wait Cheryl King and that's it you
resign you go rookie Jake King G3 Rook
GA check and Rook G4 and mag there was
some swinging back and forth twoing and
throwing do we have a game remaining
Anish giri versus bagdan
let's go to Richie Rapport and radislav
we have two minor pieces and a pawn
versus Rook reaches winning Richie's
winning
not easy though only one draw so far in
this round
the rest of them decides the results uh
oh this is Bishop H3 check and F2 and
we're gonna see Bishop at Knight versus
King one more time
oh no I was gonna play F2 and fall for
it myself okay King G3 and he's still
not threatening F2
how funny well he has to push it and
then okay not testing reaches knowledge
of checkmate with Knight and Bishop oh
because you do have King D2 right so the
King was on E3 in one moment on you had
to go on the other side
and Radisson said no no no you just you
just lost it
that would be so unfair uh VAR uh
give us updates what happened right well
our level one game was just a solid draw
as I mentioned that both players Wesley
and him needed a little break so that
was just a normal game but this game
caught my eye I wanted to see this
moment here very sharp position between
with tashek and Report here so let's
take a look this again we see some crazy
imbalance by Richie here and he's doing
really well here but still here to play
a couple of more accurate moves here
before you know he got to the winning
positions Rook takes C8 98 we see Queen
E2 you you do need to get the pieces
developed here if the piece are
Consolidated then you're doing really
well here but you need couple of more
moves here so he played the move Knight
D6 and now we see this idea there was a
bishop G6 here played
and now we see some pressure here along
this file I like this move Queen C4
trying to get the Queens off the board
because blocking is now getting exposed
as well so exchanging the Queens will
help white block in this position and
now Bishop page seven King takes H7 and
he ended up winning the B2 pawn and now
and eventually converting into a win
here so again once again we see a very
complicated game by report but he is
winning now again now he won two in a
row so he's got a little bit of momentum
going for himself
yeah thank you Vara and through the
magic of Television uh we're just going
to replay a moment where we see magnus's
reaction to uh winning this very end of
the game Carol because he knows he looks
off today oh boy okay all right smile uh
not my finest hour right he knows that
he gave kiril some chances and he's not
happy about it but when is a win hey
look I'll take any win you offer here
are our standings after round 14. what a
change Magnus now has a two-point lead
remember when he was three behind yeah
wow it was a long time ago a long long
time ago and let's go to Warsaw
[Music]
guys Magnus is on nine and a half out of
the last 10 games this is absolutely
Bonkers but let's take a look at what
happened in this game between Maxim and
yanchish stuff is just simply not
finding his shape in today's round so
let's take a look E4 C6 and I have to
say the troubles started early with his
opening choice because already after C4
Knight C3 this position you just don't
have a lot of space as black you
suffocate and these are the type of
positions that mvl definitely enjoys
playing and um you could see that Bishop
to G5 Queen to D7 Knight to G3 castle
castle waves change but the space
Advantage remains and it doesn't seem
like you have a lot of ways to get out
of it for example if you go Knight to D5
at any point I can always just simply
take and whenever you take back I still
have space advantage and now I have
control over the C file as well Rook to
C1 things of that nature if you take
with the e-pawn now I'm going to go
Bishop to C2 exchange the light Square
Bishops and then I'm just simply going
to push my F Pawn F4 F5 simply push you
over and uh this is the problem in this
position he played the move Bishop to E7
Rook to D1 and now instinctively you
want to get out you want to eliminate
the space Advantage right that's why he
played the move F6 objectively is not a
good move you have to take on G5 accept
the fact that you will have to be on the
defensive for the rest of the game
something hard it's so difficult
especially in Blitz right yes yes you
want to still fight yes even though it
doesn't look maybe good for you but you
want to create that's the human instinct
yes yes exactly and that's why after F6
unfortunately this position is just
really really bad because while I have
everything I want and so many weaknesses
to play against on the king side as
white the E file as well a lot of
pressure as uh we've seen in the game
and you guys covered the rest of the
game black doesn't have anything on the
queen side unfortunately there's no
counter play and Duda was unable to get
any chances in this game and we all just
took it from the beginning to the end
wow old game so I was checking the game
uh Bogdan deck played against Anish giri
and yes it was a big fight box was
better actually I think like all the way
he got some kind of Advantage
um and uh okay Anish also was fighting
he moved to C5 and tried to also take
control over C file but what we're doing
really well just pay attention he
decided to keep his King in the center
why not we are moving to towards the
engine right we need the king in the
center why not to have him there yes and
he just doubled on the C file and I mean
a position looked really good and he
managed to actually at the end he
managed to get this very dangerous a
pawn I will show you the moment so but
at this moment something happened like
um Anish decided to to find his chances
on the king side he didn't exchange the
Queens he played Queen d8 looking
forward for some control play which is
Queen G6 maybe yeah yes and look I mean
A6 is running it seems like now he will
win the ball on but queen of six yes and
now roxitude I think this was the best
moment for Bogdan just to Simply repeat
like Rook C1 Rook C2 just to change this
rook in order to just make a draw and
accept the fact but okay they had only
seconds on the clock and um look what
happened after he decided to like win C3
avoiding this repetition and then Queen
H5 and then again then all started yeah
checks and he took the pawn on H2 and um
some checkmates ideas all the time so
Queen D2 was maybe the last one rookie
one keep an eye on the spawn and at the
end of the day um Anish managed to
convert this position because now you're
going down yeah
so at the end of the day he just
finished the game with his favor so
Anish won this game and walked down the
only one who managed to make a draw
today was Magnus Carlson lost he's been
playing good chess and he's been getting
good positions but unfortunately it's
all about that time situation he's
getting in time trouble early on and
unfortunately the pressure is too much
guys back to you in the studio thank you
Anastasia and thank you Christian as
we're getting closer and closer to the
championship row rounds let's take a
look at the road ahead for two key
players we'll start with a young
Kristoff Dudek right he has uh Wesley
sewing the next round coming in nice and
then diac voytastic and finish last
round he's gonna face Magnus Carlson how
important will that game be because
let's see magnus's road ahead
and Magnus has a Richard in the next
game Anish giri Levon and Duda all very
very strong players yeah that looks like
murderers Road doesn't it a little
easier road ahead than for Duda but that
all-important round 18 game really looms
large
and finally let's take a look at Wesley
so
he has Duda as we already mentioned an
mvl who's been on fire today chefchenko
was doing really well in the Blitz and
diaken the last round two dangerous last
round games uh tell us about the
standings after 14 rounds of plays
alright so we have Magnus Carlson
leading with two extra points big thanks
to that 11 and a half Point Blitz score
you can see what he's doing with field
it's amazing and Sharon second Wesley so
and Jan cristob Duda oh actually npl
yeah hello
yes and now the bone is in the fifth
place with 18 points it would be very
hard for Levon to catch up with the
litters yeah exactly too much slippage
going on there as we take a look at our
parents for round 15.
and let's see uh we have NBA elegant
chefchenko do that again so nice game
Iranian dioc Beauty boy tashek and the
Kima chap Robert against Carlson yeah
that will be our Marquee matchup Richie
versus Magnus and we're going to take a
short break and we're going to see you
on the other side for this upcoming
around the place we'll be right back
[Music]
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States boasts the world-class St Louis
chess club and the World Chess Hall of
Fame it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online for chess
merchandise autograph Collectibles chess
campus souvenirs and much much more from
quirky greeting cards to luxury chess
sets there is something for everyone at
Q Boutique and all purchases go right to
benefiting new exhibitions and programs
at the World Chess Hall of Fame
dedicated to exploring chess and its
immense impact on art and culture
located on the first floor of the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy a shopping
experience like no other and become
everyone's favorite Gift Giver if you
can shop in store make sure to check out
Q boutiquestl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
[Music]
the muni's premier season bursting with
comedy's romance and Magic Begins June
12th with the muni premiere of beautiful
the Carole King musical
the Epic summer continues with Disney's
Beauty and the Beast chess West Side
Story Little Shop of Horrors rent and
Sister Act
single tickets are now on sale at
muni.org
in Forest Park
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
welcome back everyone as our standings
after round 14.
Carlson uh leading the tournament with
two points and uh Sharon second Wesley
so young Christoph Duda and mvl dude
that's a chasing pack but two points
with only four rounds to go I think
Maggie's got this uh as the upcoming
round the pairings for round 15.
let's take a look MPL against chefchenko
do that again so Iranian diac Gary
voitashek and Robert against Carlson
well we'll start with rapper Richie and
Maggie as our premiere Game but that
Duda versus Wesley so that time for
second that's very very very nice and
let's just remind our audience what the
players are playing for right the first
place winner is going to get forty
thousand dollars second played thirty
thousand third place twenty five
thousand 175 000 in total prizes tenth
place gets seven thousand Grand Chester
points up for grabs when clear first get
a bonus of Thirteen and a lot of the
wild cards are stealing a lot of those
grand Chester or uh including Magnus
Carlson I mean if he if he steals these
uh gcp points it's bad for the players
as Wesley so uh adjusting everything
making sure is uh pieces of properly
centralized
do we have another ceremonial move I'm
not sure
um bar with four
rounds remaining
um it's the fight for second I think and
uh if you were one of the players tied
for second what would be your strategy
with four games to play yeah I think
well this game now do that versus Wesley
hugely huge game and but mvl is still in
the mix and again these three players
are fighting for the GCT points and
Magnus probably gonna take first place
and the the but but he cannot get those
points so that's a good news for Fabiano
who is actually leading the tour so far
that none of the the GCT participants
will be getting that the first first
prize points here so I definitely mvl is
looking really good but chefchenko is
very dangerous so well mvl uh playing
against as you just said the dangers
youths uh and there could be an open
Sicilian as Richie and Maggie get
underway did I see D4 yeah and the
trumpovsky uh Richie's being true to his
approach thus far in the tournament but
has he been getting good positions
that's what I want to ask in some games
he he is actually getting good positions
a lot of this games he's been taking on
F6 after the SEC uh second move C5 but
here we see Magnus playing the move E6
right so we're gonna see a little bit
different type of position here where we
see more I think a normal structure
Queen's Gambit declines or
what can happen after C5 after C5
normally played the move E3 here E3 you
can also play E4 I'm pretty sure E4 I've
seen it yes E4 is a move as well here
it's the second most popular move takes
E5 G5
well that's chaos it invites chaos at
least five more sedate yes E3 played
yeah the most popular move
trade trade Bishop E7 breaking the pin
excuse me
I just didn't play D5 he was waiting to
see if Richard was going to play C4 or
not yeah because black interest to play
D6 or D5 exactly when you see these
pawns on D7 and E6 it's a natural
instinct to Vian Shadow because then the
bishop will be on the open diagonal
Bishop D3 with seeing we've seen Maggie
uh playing the Polish with B5 and Bishop
A6 uh basically saying I respect this
bishop uh looking both ways uh let me
trade them off Queen
F3 attacking The Rook so deep uh I think
we're in uh new territory already uh
different uh approaches by both players
as they try to Outfox one another what's
going on bar yeah definitely new
territory this movie Space six has not
been played that many times uh more
natural movies of course to play Bishop
B7 there right and the setup that we
usually black wants to do there is
Bishop B7 castle and you play the move
D6 and ibd7 in that position right but
here we saw the move Queen F3 and then
the fireplate I don't know uh if this is
really good for what because the queen
on F3 is uh looks funny misplaced here
yes
it it's kind of inviting E6 E5 a move
that you don't necessarily want to play
but by the way Knight we have some
breaking news that mvl is already losing
it's -3 for him against Carol
mvl again with the white pieces he did
something bad in the opening 94 by the
way you were mentioning VAR that the
White Queen on F3 a bit misplaced and
the move 94 seeks to take advantage of
that Bishop takes E7 Knight D2 takes D2
is the Intermezzo King takes D2 and now
fake castle Yeah well actually 94 it's
not the best mode because that will
actually take off some of the pressure
okay and uh White is actually fine in
that line with Bishop E7 okay what was
the best move for for instead of 94 the
best one would have been just to play
the move Rook C8 Rook C8 because now if
your Castle yeah you're gonna run into
this tactic then
E2 yeah Queen takes E2 Knight takes D4
okay we'll just catch up with the
players because this did not happen
Knight E4 did take place Bishop takes
Queen takes F7 check was this missed by
Maggie King takes F7 Bishop takes Knight
and we're gonna take on B2 the material
is going to be even but there's two
Bishops that are weakness
black better the bishop on A6 my knight
on B2 looking good looking good and I
think black's Kink is right now better
than White's King as well uh maybe a
Miss misjudgment by the way the move
Rook C8 invites Bishop takes E2 and
Knight takes D4
winning material with this most terrible
move and now after Rook C8 Magnus is
about to win another wow wow just one
bad move and Richie immediately sees it
I mean he immediately recognizes is that
Bishop takes E2 Knight takes D4 the
bishop on C2 is going to be x-rayed
x-ray attack and the
shaking of the head as Richie's
B1 Rook B1 night seat and by the way the
tactic is still existing it still exists
right night is coming to A3 what are you
doing about your Bishop again the
shaking of the head we've seen Richie do
this a lot yeah this queen F7 was really
a nice move that Spectators would
appreciate but in reality it was just
not that good and gave Magnus a better
end game wow and once again we saw
Richie taking a lot of chances instead
of just going for a more solid approach
by taking the pawn on D5
it and it's he has a completely winning
position when when it goes well it's
sort of like you're running downhill it
just I mean nobody's tackling you you're
you just feel you have this feeling of
invincibility you're unstoppable Bishop
F4 but Knight A3 we know what mag is on
magnus's mind he wants to take on E2 and
then take on C2 well
right away there's another tactic now
I'm not sure night before
Rook D2
there's a knight D3 check oh and if I go
King do you want to have Knight F2 if I
go again
Richie just resigned wow wow it's over
that fast let's jump to the game of Duda
versus Wesley so because as we know this
is so crucial for the grand chess tour
standings and what do we have
a lot of Pawns on the great side yeah
but that's one of the ugliest structures
you're gonna see uh take a photo uh that
I would be seven I think white can play
Queen D5 and fix some pawns and be up a
pawn in the end game
yeah but okay so King takes B7 Queen D5
check East C6 go ahead trade Queen you
play C6 I thought I had Queen A5
oh that's nasty Queen A5 you're
absolutely right so Queen D5 check is
the golden move here and he's done it I
thought I was gonna go C7 C6 and after
the queen trade I was gonna happily
March my king up the board but no Queen
takes D5 and you fix the structure yes
but now Wesley's King is doing better
than White's King true and and he saved
the game because that's what it's about
right he's behind material will he be
able to save the game very active King
VAR for Wesley is that is that enough
for him no I think the end game is is
lost even though he's getting some
activity King F1 now simply bring the
king to the 3c4 easy the extra Pawn same
color Bishops
should be a win here so King A5 Bishop
A7 King A4 and the timing is favorable
for white yeah King guitar King B3 and
you get the King on D3 well this would
be a huge result for Duda because it
would really help him secure the second
place because MBL is MBL okay
and Wesley I was also sharing second
place so if do that if it's Wesley now
he'll be in clear second F7 F5 that
doesn't disturb the equilibrium F2 F3
and just maintaining the structure E4 D5
not worried about F4 I can drop my
Bishop back maintain the tension against
the A7 Pawn
now for unfortunately from uh Wesley's
point of view you know something
desirable like C5 in order to be able to
play King A5 well on the song
you can't approach the C6 Pawn
yeah I don't see any ideas for Wesley
that would save this game as the king is
going to get to D3 just in time to meet
King B3 with King D3
and then the Bishops of opposite the
Bishops of
um same color I just push push whoa whoa
whoa Bishop C5 inviting a king upon
ending I think it's just over right we
can take and King D2
I'll do the triangulation
or C4 right away C4 or H4 I think or
even
it's not even close though just yeah
you're right just C4 check King B4 trade
the Bishops and go King C3 and you have
to go back
that's resigned C4 is a three H4
so maybe white should play H4 first
King before G3 King C5 then King C3
absolutely right
right
C4 check King before trade play H4 King
B4 play G3 and that's the zooks one yes
I was trying to set up yes because if
King goes to B3 then C5 and
and this is the crucial moment to H his
time calculated and there we go and now
after King B4 G3 party my pick Wesley
going down oh no oh no
oh no G3
Kingston five King C3 and that's what we
call opposition yes
and I do see envel lost his game wow
uh by the way uh Carol is playing a role
of spoiler I mean that is a a very very
hurtful loss for mvl now the pawn is on
C6 it means that the Breakthrough Pawn
D6 the king cannot remain active D6 is a
upon break the King has to play a
passive role and White's King can play
an active role it's really that simple
now
um
did you say uh we've got Anish
and Lavon versus
dioc what would you like uh well we have
Anish on the on the screen so let's take
a look there we go uh four Bishop ending
you don't see that very often but it
looks like I don't think she's got
uh almost uh I want to say in wrestling
terms a full Mount but how to break
that's the question yeah right you have
everything but how to break this we have
a fortress
by the way we do we are being told that
Lavon who's been in a spin cycle has won
so again all the size of results we're
just waiting for this game can we make
it five for five how do we break through
uh
dark Square Bishops so that we make the
move King E5 possible but even after
that King E7
okay then I can go E4 F5
so it would be interesting to see Magnus
played this with white since he doesn't
believe it fortresses how he would break
this yes
uh what do the engines tell us uh VAR
the evaluation is plus four but it's
it's not showing the concrete plan I
think if you exchange the dark School
Bishop yes sir you will definitely win
the game okay so but that's something
black should try to avoid exchanging
because after that you put the King on
E5 and have the F5 breakthrough right
you will win that game but uh in the
meantime it's still not not as easy
Anish has only nine seconds and wait
Tasha definitely not gonna exchange the
Bishops yeah his being is an obstinate
most stubborn best not trading the
Bishops to the idea because white
doesn't have F5 G5 is always hanging so
how does white improve can I go Bishop
to D6 and King to E5 and then
Bishop to ba King to DC
I'm trying I'm trying to you know like I
can always play Bishop E7 that is true
so here he's going King to G4 so he can
go F5 I'm not sure where he's heading
with his King Anisha is just yeah you're
not gaining us much time you know
okay here we have it The Big Break F5
he's put all of his marbles behind this
one now I'm assuming you don't want to
take and open up the bishop on um F3
we've just seen now just Bishop D7 and
it's just oh that E5 is a pretty move F5
is completely hanging but black should
not touch no it's a now it's a easy draw
now there is absolutely no plan in this
position that is right Bishop E8 and
just sit
don't allow Bishop takes G6
uh by white so black needs to just move
the bishop back and forth and wait yes
you have a bishop to this the E8
radislav founder and we finally have a
draw
yay no no 100 scores uh Anish loves the
dress VAR uh tell us what happened in
this round uh the game that caught my of
course Magnus won very easily and I
think he's just one step closer now to
win this tournament but Levon finally
won a game and I want to show you a
moment from his game he he's playing
against deakir and in this position The
Arc had to actually take only five
Bishop takes E5 F takes E5 play like
Queen A3 here he's he's slightly worse
here but nevertheless position is very
solid he can play Rook ac8 here it's
it's hard to break through here but
instead he played the natural move Rook
a C8 but I think he he missed what level
is trying to do with this muruk fd1 now
we see the move Knight E4 coming in
attacking the queen and the problem is
you don't have a good Square for the
queen to go to because this Knight F7
sacrifice is going to take place so he
played the move in Queen C7 and now we
see the move Knight takes F7 if you take
back with the King you have a knight G5
check Queen E6 coming up 96 as well so
this is actually a very big Advantage
for Levon and now I took on De Knight
takes d8
Rook takes d8 Bishop exchanging the
Rooks and Bishop E4 so you have two
pawns and a rook for two minor pieces
but their weakness is only six and B6
and it was not easy to convert this but
Levon managed to win the game at the end
and finally score a victory
thank you for that bar and once again
let's take a look at our standings
update ourselves through round 15 of
Blitz
all right Magnus Crossing still leading
with two points and the Yankees have to
run now in the clear second place and
sharing third Wesley and mvf with a big
matchup between Wesley and mvl coming up
but first let's jump to Poland and get a
view uh from the playing Hall
but what an incredible game what an
incredible performance for Magnus in the
blitz portion let's take a look at his
line score because this is a absolutely
incredible I I don't think I've seen
anything close to this performance in
the grandchester or up to this point so
let's take a look at that he started off
slowly one win lost against Wesley and
then a couple of draws and everybody was
writing him off myself included Gary
He's not in shape he's probably going to
fight for second place things of that
nature take a look at what happened
after that
seven wins in a row he made a draw with
dark in round 12 and then picked it up
where he left three more why not just
for good measure and right now he's
um leading with authority two points in
the lead clear first ahead of two that
just incredible performance I have to
say for Magnus and by the way going into
the last three rounds I believe if he
wins this one and Duda does not win his
game then the tournament at least for
the first place it's over but there was
a big battle for second place yeah
speaking about dude yes and of course I
will check the game between yankee stuff
and uh who who played against Wesley so
it was a very important match because
both of them they were tied for the
second place and so what happened is
that they got this opposite castling
position where everybody is trying to
check with each other and look what
happened after I think maybe Wesley
could have tried to play something like
G5 here trying also to push the pawns it
was also maybe risky but still having
and this is something what you have to
do right to speed up a little bit you
try to maybe maybe there was another
idea to just to close a little bit what
was happening on the on the queen side
I'll give that Knight B6 inviting also
Buddha maybe even to take on B6 and then
push A5 but he decided to go for btec 66
which also looks very logical you're
trying still to ruin uh the pawn
structure and also open some files and
after Knight C4 which was I think the
idea of Wesley that he exchanged those
Knights Rook D1 Wesley tried actually to
exchange all the pieces so he played
Rook d8 but what I think happened is
that he probably missed this move very
nice move up to the queen D1 when you
move your queen back and normally this
moves when you miss very often right I
think he was expecting it yeah exactly
and then he thought to take maybe on C4
and now it's complicated this is okay
this is okay it acts as a shield yes
this is what you expect in the previous
rounds yes it's somehow it's it can also
be in favor of like despawn on B7 so it
didn't happen so he played this nice
move Queen D1 and after Bishop B7 there
is some difference because after taken
here if black now takes on C4 there is
some unpleasant consequences after Queen
before yes so now I mean the only move
really like because Checkmate is the
threat yes so the only move is to go
back and um I think yes Queen is six and
then like Queen E8 some kind of computer
line but it's it looks a little bit
scary for black because the bishop and
queen are attack are attacking this
because you also have this idea of Queen
to B5 and Bishop takes A7 I mean it's
just some B8 yes after 30 years after
okay there's a way to defend perhaps you
can go C5 or something that's too many
points exactly yes so and it was very
dangerous so I think Queen D1 was the
case this is what maybe he missed or
something like that and after that look
what happened they just simply went to
descending and we spawned up uh do the
converted it really nicely
um they I mean played this visual
bending and at the end
um bestly proposed Bishops Bishop
exchange but we know that on endic was
on up it's a very pleasant ending and
it's easy easy for do that yes so he'll
he managed to win and it's really
important win if he's still trying to
catch up with Magnus he of course he has
two points behind but still I mean it's
great that he managed to win this game
and
um
oh for sure yes you should have to climb
for first position but this is a crucial
victory for the second position at least
now let's take a look at what happened
in the game between Richie no sorry not
Richie versus Magnus you guys saw that
but the one between mvl and kiril
because mvl has been having a pretty
decent event he won this game now
against lebonaronian and the last round
as well so he was really in a good mood
I saw him there laughing you know not a
good mood after this one because take a
look at what happened really Sicilian by
kiril we've seen him actually I say this
type of dragon structures he really is
important
yes and now mvl accepts the pawn
sacrifice which I don't think is the
right decision because after Castle D3
and by the way things went South very
very early on for mvl in this game F4 D6
despite the fact that I'm a pawn down
after a very typical break D4 a C4
excuse me and that weakens the pawn on
e4 if you do take on e4 I'm going to
take back with the Rook on e4 then I'm
going to go Bishop to A6 put a lot of
pressure on the pawn on C4 and you're
lacking a very important piece the light
Square Bishop which you gave
you definitely need it and to be honest
after C4 despite the fact that black is
a pawn down he's already much better in
the position and mvl was unable to get
um back into the game D5 everything with
Tempo Bishop Basics Tempo on the queen
queen B6 Tempo on the king D5 he's not
letting white killer that is uh develop
his pieces on the queen side if you
manage to go B3 Bishop B2 maybe you have
a chance to survive but if you don't do
that that's game over and it was game
over because after Knight takes F2 uh
black kiril picked up the exchange and
he was never bad for four years actually
I mean I'm happy to see kiril coming
back because he just lost this game
against Magnus Carlson and normally you
are not so happy about it but he managed
to
great result for Ukrainian Romanian
player absolutely absolutely now let's
take a look at the standings as we go
into the final three rounds
so Magnus Carlson is leading 22 and a
half points yeah two points ahead of
younger 10 and a half out of 11 for
today that that's not bad not bad not
bad at all and Wesley so is on the third
position together with Maxima Shiela
grab levonaroni and just have a point
behind with 19 points still a big battle
for uh first place but also for second
place a lot of players buying for those
grand Chester points guys exciting few
last rounds coming up we're going to go
on a short commercial break and we'll be
back shortly don't
[Music]
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chess sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other make sure to check out Q
Boutique stl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
foreign
[Music]
thank you
welcome back everybody to our show after
15 rounds of exciting Blitz these are
our standings now see we have Magnus
Carlson lead in the tournament with 22
and a half points and two points behind
is Jan Cristo of Duda and in the third
place sharing Wesley so and mvl just
look at that Blitz score 12 and a half
nobody even close to that score remotely
close as we take a look at the upcoming
uh round 16 Blitz pairings let's take a
look chefchenko against Robert Carlson
against giri we just have to it's the
Magnus Carlson show everybody look at
what he's doing well that'll be our
Marquee game correct voice
and Wesley so against MBL well that's
got to be our backup plan uh for sure
sorry respects for Doodles but let's
take a look at what Magnus has done with
his line score I mean remember these are
the world's best players he's doing this
against bar can you recall he did this
once on a grand chest tour a couple of
years ago but this is remarkable
absolutely absolutely incredible I mean
he made one draw in the last 12 games I
mean it's just it's just amazing and he
can clinch this guys if he wins this
game and Duda doesn't win he can clinch
it
wow and I remember one Wesley so Maggie
uh horse race and maybe it was mvl and
Magnus having a horse race in one of
these Blitz rapid combinations but this
is just extraordinary in that seven in a
row
today words fail
yeah
that's crazy that's crazy talk uh I mean
Bobby Fisher how do you explain that I
don't I don't okay it has been a
combination of lock skill and everything
else but everything is really Fallen his
way
one player things have just gone very
badly for Lavon aronian he fell off
um but for Duda I mean you know he's
still in there he's he is and if he
keeps winning and Magnus slip somewhere
in the last round Dura has a chance to
defeat Magnus that's the last round it
is there we see uh Daniel Dia playing
the white pieces against John Kristoff
uh but for Duda it's like I'm having an
excellent tournament everybody well
somebody please stop Magnus that's all
I'm asking yes no I mean yeah that's
what he's hoping for so how to win all
his games and Magnus drop one game and
then in in a situation where his one
point behind Magnus but he controls his
Destiny if he can win that last game
against him it looks like we do have a
special opening move is that the voreal
uh
polygon it looks like I mean it did and
we do have uh Anish gear as black Anish
he can't complain he's had the winning
positions but whether he's been winning
or drawing them he hasn't been scoring
and uh still a dangerous opponent
wounded or Not Bar absolutely Anish can
be the spoiler and Magnus needs to be
you know just just play his uh the game
the way he's been playing the you know
last day in half so
now I like this Choice exchange
validation and just get a safe and
comfortable position solid Bishop F4
I've always felt that in that particular
position after Bishop F4 the move A7 A6
is rather useful if you see E3 then the
move Bishop G4 can be a better place but
uh all very very standard moves we've
seen it actually in the
foreign
is the best move this was played by
vishiana against kramnik in 2008 World
Championship you're right and bond yes
and this is just going to be an end game
up upon for Magnus most likely it will
be a draw but you you're still pressing
a little bit and definitely you're
playing for two results you're never
gonna lose this position and we can
never say it's a draw when Magnus is
playing an equal position right but you
were you're right that was from Bonn uh
the the world championship match between
Vladimir kramnik and vision and I think
a few people tested this ending as well
and the the tests usually end and draws
the idea of course we've got the Bishops
of opposite color a pawn down but we're
going to have an active Rook on C2 white
is looking to most likely Play Moves
Like F3 and trying to neutralize
um sorry
I think it's a technical position maybe
more action is going on in the game uh
well Wesley already finished his game
check in with Duda since he's the only
one who can possibly catch Magnus and he
is playing Daniel diach yes and what do
we have here I think you had Carol con
yes
D3 okay
and quickly we'll catch up with the
players G3
I always like Sicilia yeah I was about
to say I played the ComiCon a lot but I
cannot recall ever achieving this
position with either side
um Bishop E3 uh what does the theory
tell us about this position bar
only one game played in a database and
it looks like white is maybe a little
bit better there is some pressure
against the B6 pawn and normally you
would like to have your knight on D7 in
this position to keep that diagonal open
for your light Square Bishop instead of
the Knight on C6
but here I think black can continue with
the move Rook d8 which makes sense to
try to gain the tempo against the queen
yeah you have to play Queen E2
and then try to liquidate some pieces
with the move 95.
Knight E5 yes so Black's not in a rush
the castle Rook d8 on the board
uh Queen E2 not a rush to cash flow but
yeah there is some reasons to to get on
the uh by the way the C4 Pawn doesn't
stand out a little bit Rook d8 Queen E2
Knight A5 is that an overreach Knight A5
is a move as well but then there is a
tactical shot Knight takes D Knight to
D5
did not see it and if you take Ed there
is Bishop takes B6 check it's very
Sicilian idea 95. I've never seen it in
Carroll County right uh ghosts of
Michael Tall uh reaching uh into this
okay but Rook d8 Queen E2 and uh Daniel
as is his habit uh Burns clock not
necessarily in my view at times and uh
is that a factor yet and by the way I do
believe Knight A5 came on the board and
this was Knight D5 was the suggestion
yes 95 was the top move wow Knight D2
came very quickly allowing the trade of
the light squared Bishops I would
definitely want to trade this bishop
because I just feel that that fianchetto
Bishop just makes White's King so safe
I feel like okay I weaken a little bit
my opponent's position now I'm anxious
to Castle maybe bishop E5 if I don't
blunder upon the bishop takes B6
so yeah I think I'm just castling here
um overall uh VAR engines assessment
evenish yeah it's about equal here
Bishop C5 is another move that engines
like it just try to exchange the ducks
with Bishops as well you can take away
some pressure from the B6 Pawn gotcha I
have some update in a different game
live one is looking much worse
who is he playing he's playing voytastic
I felt like a partial score Lavon much
worse
and this is an important game for live
on because if he can score another win
he will have a chance maybe to finish in
top three at the at the moment the first
place is out but you know there are some
chances to catch up you know finishing
in a Podium well those grand Chester
points are being taken by wild cards
Magnus
likely to take 13 points away from the
field and if Lavon a wild card could
finish in the PO you know the podium
he'll be taking away points from players
like Wesley so for example and Fabio
will be thanking them both exactly
dinner's on me guys rook ac1 and I like
what you suggested there a moment ago
Bishop C5 certainly caught my eye uh the
moment you mentioned it bar you just
take away the pressure from B6 for a
moment and what if I go Bishop G5 then I
go back they should go to B7 right and
I'm not afraid of Bishop F6 so yeah
Bishop
Bishop C5 feels like the right way this
is surprising but Duda has less time
than diak and he played Bishop C5 after
a long thing
I think Daniel is uh tasered he's not
used to being ahead on the clock
certainly not by a whole minute I need
to spend some time
uh Bishop C5 uh by Duda again uh you
know dude has been having a great
tournament he's the defending Champion
he won this event last year and he
performed excellently in the blitz it's
just that this has just been having you
know he's playing what you can do when
Magnus scores nine and a half out of ten
like it's ridiculous right and I mean I
remember you know Gary Kasparov doing
this in the uh it was the GMA World Cup
the grand Masters Association he he
would play in some of these tournaments
where he scored like plus eight and you
know I'd have some decent result I don't
know plus three and I'm thinking you
know like I'm fighting for first right
yes exactly exactly uh night back to C60
he didn't even he he's showing his
contempt uh I'm not worried about things
about Bishop takes F6
as his Pawn would go to F5 and uh the
black Bishop can go back to G7 if needed
the king side would be completely safe
yeah and this move Knight C6 by the way
hey you know the square D4 is a very
attractive Outpost and if I provoke
Knight F3 the trading of knights after
94 Knight takes D4 Bishop takes D4 black
looks pretty fine here uh or I see
you've got another game uh that's caught
your eye yeah I was I was looking at
some other games as well here yes uh
Knight C6 now back Bishop F6 is not that
dangerous in the current position for
Duda because he can Retreat Bishop B7
then put the pawn on F5 and at some
point we know the queen is going to go
on B7 try to create some pressure on
that diagonal so at the moment it's just
completely equal the evaluation and
dayak has been thinking and now do that
is once again ahead on a clock
and everything is right with the world
again the Eric is in time trouble
excellent excellent yeah I I thought I
was in a parallel universe there for a
moment when you told me that Duda was a
minute behind on the clock uh
fortunately if we check back with
magnus's game it looks like a opposite
color Bishop end game and a Dedra
uh still a little bit of Tricks but this
should be a draw here I mean his plan is
to bring the king to before and push the
pawn A4 but yeah well it's going to be
very hard to win this if black captures
puts his King even on A8 and his Bishop
on G4
it's it's dead dead draw right I mean
okay I somehow he got in a passer on the
H file wait a minute I have to take that
no I could go 55 check sorry exchange E5
exchange everything and then run with
the King on A8 and just sacrifice the
bishop for the H Pawn correct
so E5 shag should draw it on the spot
just not the other way if you sacrifice
Bishop for the a pawn and you run to the
h8 yeah that's not the corner you wanted
there he he's got it E5 and Magnus knows
that uh that's the spoiler
yes um well would they change love if
you don't make a mistake there you go
we're gonna jump back to the dioc versus
Duty game undoubtedly this game is going
to end in a draw uh for Anisha and wait
a minute uh there's a 95 uh hip-hop just
uh came as we left it Knight D5 takes
takes well the bishop has got to go back
to G7 which happened Knight F4
okay A little bit of uh tickling there
have been few more moves on the board
and queens are off the board and there
goes the danger right there yeah if
anyone's better here it has to be black
precisely the Rooks uh and the bishop
coordinate better than the rook in the
night and because of the vulnerability
oh of the black king the trade of Queens
did help dude not that uh he you know
white was going to be assaulting
anything deadly or anything like that
but okay let's get it caught up with the
play Rook C8 oh
on his pins this City Pawn in danger or
is it safe I always ask myself those
questions asset or liability I like this
move Bishop H6
suggesting that it's black who wants to
play for the win he can pick up one
extra Pawn on our floor let's do it
Duda says give me that guy of course it
should be equal after Rook B2 or Rook D2
equal is strong let's say the
compensation is excellent
uh I would just wouldn't want to say
equal right I'm just so used to assuming
Rook end games are a draw even with the
extra Pawn but in bleeds that's and by
the way we did get an update uh Magnus
and Gary have drawn and now it's very
very clear that Duda has every
reason to play for a win he's a he's got
the extra Pawn E5 and F4 oh no this is
looking great for black it absolutely is
E5 F4 King F5 slow slow slow incremental
progress and why it is extremely passive
I'm thinking this could just be a flat
out
VAR absolutely just complete the winning
King is gonna go on E6 and uh another
Pawn is yeah you don't have any Contra
play yeah Rook B5 and I think we're
gonna see a resignation soon wait a
minute everything was okay and then and
then it it was okay until it wasn't as
it always is
and the King might just triumphantly
walk King to D4 and
came to E3
the king when will the game uh-oh could
be a meeting that already being set up
here let's not forget about the time
maybe we have five seconds maybe he did
not need Rook G6 maybe King F4 was so
let me Supply quickly yes
yes
one of the strange things I just don't
understand how they do it it must be a
sixth sense uh Duda has made Moves
pressed his clock with one second
it's like he just feels that he's got
the time and
makes these moves do not just need to
trade Rooks here just go Rook C5 and
just go rock C2 and trade once he trades
one pair of Rooks he will easily win
this position how about King A3
so that he can go Rook A2 or something
like that but I agree with you start
pushing the pawn like he just did yes
trade one pair of Rooks just as you said
we have a few updates live on June oh he
will trade the Rooks and there you go
report one against stripchenko
would you report one against uh
yeah dude has completely winning but
again he just needs to play a little
fast
the clock
and if only White's King was in a better
position
then white could draw this
I think we're about to see a resignation
after King C1
there we go
and uh
white will have to give up his Rook
actually when you have two seconds on
the clock and you have to promote to a
queen yeah that can be awkward promoting
to a queen king E3 and I think that's
enough that's enough yes very good
important win for Duda yeah yes he is he
keeps his second position let's put it
that way very very important and
the audience very appreciative of a
Polish crowd there tell us what happened
in this round Laura in this round we saw
three draws guys and the game that
caught my eye was the Levon game he was
actually completely losing against for
Tasha he got lucky and saved the end
game but I want to show you the moment
where he made a big mistake and watasha
got a winning position so it wasn't it
was an English opening here and it's
more or less equal position here and the
last move is Rook ac1 you can play the
move Bishop F5 or Knight D5 normal
position but like one goes for this move
night before it looks like an
interesting tactic sacrificing the night
they pick up the uh Knight on before but
it's actually a mistake because he's
gonna drop this E5 Pawn at the end of
the the sequence here so a takes B4
Bishop B5 and now we see the move Knight
takes C5 not only winning the pawn but
also combining the defense of the D3
pawn and that also opened up the bishop
on B7 so after this tactic white has a
very big Advantage so Levon took with
the bishop Bishop takes B7 now attacking
The Rook again uh extra Pawn Rook E6 and
now Knight C6 was played and they they
reached to this end game which was
simply winning for white he won the pawn
on C7 Bishop B7 Rook B7 and
I'm really surprised he didn't play the
move Rook D2 here this would have been a
very nice move just to win the game just
completely shut down all the Contra play
on the second rank the next one will
pick up the panel before this would have
won very easily for with Ash against he
took and allowed to move Rook C2 and
this is still winning but your pawns are
more doubled here again technically
winning end game here he had to play the
move Rook d8 Rook B8 and start advancing
the pawn and he would have converted it
but instead he played the move Rook D3
still good winning chances but after
some inaccuracies that I want to manage
to defend this difficult end game two
pawns down uh amazing uh standings uh
let's take a look
I forgot the number around 16 rounds and
uh Magnus Carlos still in the clear lead
uh now one and a half Point ahead of
Duda so do that in the clear second and
then still sharing third place Wesley so
and mvl we can't call it for Magnus
because in fact the last round is going
to feature uh Madness and do the uh
fighting it up and that could be the
designer
and more from Warsaw Poland
so in order to control his fate all he
needs to do do that that is is catch uh
have a point in this round compared to
Magnus so if he wins and Magnus makes a
draw then still Duda will have his faith
in his hands going into the final round
this is very very exciting now Anastasia
you were watching this game between
Wesley and MV of yes it was actually a
theoretical draw and which was this
ration happened many times before and
Maxim and both Wesley they were aware of
this line for sure and I believe that
both of them decided to kind of take a
break after really difficult rounds
previously games you know so they know
both of them that last two runs are the
most critical they're decisive so
decided not to spend too much energy
it's a very nice line actually yeah nice
line which actually leads to the the
trade all the pieces basically and then
the position is like finishes in a draw
so you sacrifice the queen but you get
this Perpetual check and it's very nice
because Rook to D7 is forced right yes
because you can you cannot do it
somewhere else because the bishop will
be taken otherwise yes you can you can
do this it takes A7 but this is a little
bit trickiest yeah very very tricky you
can go when I take stuff like this
better a little bit yes so we don't we
don't do this we just make a sure Rook
the seven finishes the game in the draw
make a draw and they actually finished
in like two what you were checking now
Christian I was looking at the game uh
that you guys saw in the studio caught
up in the last few moments with that is
the game between bogd and Daniel deck
and Jan shustoff Duda so let's take a
look at what happened and you know
Yankee stuff needs to win he knows of
course he knows that he needs to win or
to catch up with Magnus because Magnus
is not really slowing down that much I'm
sure at all
but still you know that's really
impressive how young stuff is still
trying you know he's just pushing his
luck that's great yes and everything
will be solved in the last round he's a
fighter he's he really is a fighter and
Bishop to uh G2 B6 Castle Bishop to B7
we see by the way this uh Karo Khan once
again and the avoidance of the queen
trade with the smooth Queen to C7 he's
looking for a long game and he knows
what bogdan's weakness is in business
exactly exactly and this is exactly what
we see in this game as well as you can
see some exchanges of the pieces some
change in the structure it looks like
white is getting to the black king but
they don't have a lot of forces around
my black king so that's more or less
okay for a black I really like this move
Queen to B7 setting up this potential
pin on the long diagonal King to G1 drop
back Knight to D4 and now we see this
straight
95 was interesting yes so Bishops should
be kept yes this bishop is really nice
position if you take on D5 I take on D4
we exchange everything is going to be a
draw yeah do the signal from the very
early on that he doesn't want to draw he
wants elongate this is exactly what he
got and now despite the fact that the
material is very limited you have some
problems and especially after this move
Bishop page I think he missed it yes I
think he forgot about sometimes you
forget about this side move especially
H6 yes and this is just a point up rook
to C6 he blocks the pawn yes very nice
very nice route to D7 get the king
towards the center yes uh just an
exemplary way to finish this game slowly
slowly push your opponent away
all I have to worry about these checks
there's a lot of checks from dogs
but he did it really great yes his
technique
a little bit gain some time on on the
clock and at the right moment once you
release the tension on the a file with
Rook to D7 now I finally can push the
pawn A4 and this was it cover up with
the Rooks exchange one pair of hooks and
then go on to win this game yes
that's a great game and I'm sure
everybody is like rooting for him right
now in this plane venue same time also
for Magnus you know they get definitely
most of uploads from the public huge
huge game coming up that could
potentially decide the tournament but
could also lengthen the tournament to
the final last round guys we're going to
go on a short commercial break and we'll
be back shortly
[Music]
thank you
meet me
in Forest Park the muni's premier season
bursting with comedies romance and Magic
Begins June 12th with the muni premiere
of beautiful the Carole King musical
the Epic Summit continues with Disney's
Beauty and the Beast chess West Side
Story Little Shop of Horrors rent and
sister
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
welcome everyone thank you for joining
us we are in the championship rounds two
to go and after 16 rounds of Blitz the
standings Nasi Magnus Carlson in the
clear first place and young Christoph
Duda hoping to catch him he's one and a
half Point behind him we can't call it
yet because they are due to play each
other in the final round but Wesley so
Wesley so on mvl share in the third
place exactly and tell us about the
pairings for this the penultimate round
so again chefchenko mvl diach Duda boy
Tasha all polish match iron Carlson
there's our Marquee match-up but the
dude of uh radislav game will be our
backup and Gary against rapport
ending
It's Beginning ready there we yeah I was
waiting for the view from
yeah at the playing Hall and I just want
to give a big shout out to the crowds
that have come to this magnificent
Museum and applauding the players that
is so cool that iconic pictures of
Magnus signing foreign
that is so so heartwarming I mean it
makes uh us feel really really good as
Magnus reaching for his water coming to
the
versus Magnus wow these two players have
met so much over the last I'm going to
say 15 years yeah and I remember them
having their fights and the candidates
remember that before he became the
Challenger Levon actually knocked Magnus
out of the candidates in the match
before London 2013. as we are off E4
Magnus has been all over the map with
his defenses and with a more classical
choice I was about to save things have
calmed down with the
um Italian
uh Joko piano he chose a solid opening
in this game this is a critical game
just in case you know if Levon wins this
and Duda wins his game now it's going to
be only half a point in lead so it's
very important for Magnus to score in
this game
that's why Magnus doesn't want to take a
huge Risk by playing something like B5
or B6 animal one exactly now that is a
strange uh picture there on the left as
uh somehow that's not the the that's
from the last round yeah that we
expected to have by the way this is a
repeat of our of a game that was played
earlier in the tournament yes yes and
maybe it was
lyrics thank you for that H7 H6 I like
that move very very much just stopping
this bishop to G5 even though you didn't
hunt down the bishop on B3 that's fine I
I think after Bishop D7 well you tell
asvar what's what the theory in the
statistics tell us no games in a
database already here they're after
opening so black has two options here so
you can play Bishop D7 here just
exchange the Bishops makes sense and or
he can play the move Knight C6 which is
gonna gonna Force the move C3 because
the bishop on A4 is hanging and then he
plays the more Bishop G4 and I think
that's where we have uh in in the game
what happened yes and it seems like we
had transposed back to a game until the
move Bishop B3 and now we're again in
novel territory yes it's a new new
position here and now a queen D7 played
my back Magnus he's got this pin here
and we know this pin is very a very
annoying and now Levon needs to figure
out how to continue here so he can start
with the move rookie one
and here Magnus has a choice actually he
can play the move long Castle
long Castle yes okay and then and then
possibly you know you want to play the
move quick D5 here and try to put
pressure on D3 here he has played B6 B5
which I find much more attractive
positionally that also indicates that
he's not planning to Castle long right
well I've got the double pawns right so
it kind of makes sense for me to Aspire
to play the move B5 B4 the move d4 was
played inviting Bishop takes F3 would
that be an overreach by Magnus trying to
win a pawn no it's the best move Bishop
takes F3 done it and are we going to see
GF no
GF you just don't you don't play that's
not the way you play Chance the queen
would come to H3 and exactly uh that's
so we're about to see Queen takes he
took us upon
wow not expecting that she takes F3 and
G5 instantly as Maggie is saying hey
wait guy uh I can't win this three
tournament in this round right
absolutely G5 is an excellent move to
stop all the F4 ideas and I don't like
this for Levon Knights are stronger in a
close position guys we know that and
again Magnus wins this it's over he's
the winner of the tournament but he has
a Levon has a chance to exchange queens
now which would make his King feel a lot
safer exactly I would probably no let me
correct my I will certainly uh be eager
to trade queens and I would take the
pawn on not the fact that I'm happier
about it but just I know I'm not going
to get mated at least with the Queens
off the board at least not right she's
very scary with Queen coming to age
three and he's going for it yes I mean
just hack that off because
Queenie was coming to H3 the Knight was
going to go to G6 and pop to F4 and it
would have been snap crackle pop uh okay
um I'm thinking that the a file might be
useful so I'm more attracted to move
Rook E1 to D1 myself I born Bishop F7
check and I probably want to get my king
back into
back to the center yes it's not very
nice on each one
and exactly what should black play here
should uh I'm thinking Bishop F7 is a
threat guys F6 and maybe on a good day
just kind of Park your King five six
seconds still go Bishop F7 check or
excuse me you're absolutely right so
black needs to move the knight from this
Knight F6 probably
right F6 okay Knight F6 kinda makes
sense king of then I think I would
Castle because King Black's King in the
center won't do so well only seven
they'll be Bishop C5 check exactly I
think black should Castle on the uh King
side do we have moves for because I saw
that the Levon look was kind of moving
nervously uh with his body there no
moves yet and uh avoiding yeah now
Knight F6 played and C4 is the right
idea again when you have two Bishops you
want to open up some files some
diagonals and that's exactly what the
move C4 does level with one minute
advantage on the clock right now okay
that's going to be important by the way
uh I I was getting sensitive to the move
Knight H4 not so easy to defend the pawn
on F3 the move C4 does allow White's
Bishop to come back and of course black
doesn't want to go on I'd H4 right now
allows he takes B5 and Knight F3 exactly
and Duda has a big advantage against
voitasha guys and also the head on a
clock so there is a good chance he's
gonna win that game keeping the pressure
on Magnus as again we've got this
all-important final round coming up and
we will be crowning a champion
um I like this move castles I like
yourself I felt that Black's King was
more vulnerable in the center it's just
parked it away and from lavon's point of
view you were mentioning
open up the game uh B4 A5 uh as white
you want to get that pawn as quickly as
possible up the board King G7 should
black try to exchange one pair of Rooks
maybe Rook d8 does it benefit black or
white
um
yeah I'm kind of happy about the fact
that I've got this past Pawn potential
the candidate past Pawn that is to say
B4 B5 A5 A6 and Lavon is doing his best
uh VAR jump in and Messi has a very good
question should you should black be
looking to trade yes Rook fd8 was the
best move instead of the move can you
send in fact engines don't like to move
King G7 at all it's it's it looks like a
waste of time and it was important to
play Rook FDA in exchange one pair of
the Rooks okay and then you put that
pawn on C6 I noticed the Knight came to
H4 is it time to bring the other Knight
to F4 because now otherwise Bishop is on
B6 we can't exchange Rooks anymore yes
no this is a problem because Pawn will
go on A5 and The Rook on A3 and when you
reach the move Knight F4 he can play
let's say Bishop C4 or even Bishop F1
and white has the control of the the
file and the Knight H5 the danger is
also D7 the move Rook f-a-t-e-h shows
that black has a little awkwardness uh
things are beginning to get dangerous
for Magnus now I think A5 and Rook A3
Rook e7k Magnus is definitely an
uncomfortable position and uh he's also
down on the clock by one minute we don't
say that too often do we almost never
uh also uh Lavon can improve his King a
little bit I I like this idea of just
bringing the King by the way this
releases the bishop so that the f
Pawn is now covered by The Rook
whoa I was thinking the bishop might
have gone to C7 right to see it could
still go back yes it could still go to
C5 again something
tells me get the king a little bit
better magnus's idea is to put Knights
on maybe E6 and G6 so he can have D4 and
F4 but it takes a long time to get there
and white Bishops are also maneuvering
C5 C4 maybe yeah and I'm also thinking
that
if I can get Rook D6 and A6 in life
would be good Bishop C4 so okay
everybody's not hanging Bishop because
of Bishop C5 the old double attack
it's been working for a thousand years
and if Magnus were to play 96 I think
Levon wants to take Bishop B6 because
then
on rookie 6 I can go Rook D7
and The Rook on the seventh Rank and we
do have it on the board by the way uh
I've got a result uh Richie Rapport true
against Anish okay and he's done what
you've suggested Bishop takes E6 and
this stopped Magnus now he he sees that
Rook takes Rook D7 could be curtains he
may be forced to take with the pawn but
maybe it's not so bad to double the
Pawns
yeah
now remember we came in with a one and a
half Point uh lead for Magnus so all he
needs really is a draw and for duty to
draw and he's clinched right but uh far
earlier told us that Duda is better
trying to win but he lost some of his
advantage on the port and on the clock
as well here okay so it's maybe very
slightly better for him
either I just wanted to say why are we
thinking Magnus is going to draw this
this looks terrible Bishop C5 and this
Pawn on B7 if that falls
that a pawn is just it's touchdown I
think that pawn is falling because on
Rook Piedra can attack with the bishop
oh look at this nasty move V5 so there's
some back rank made against the King
after a b
okay yes there's a Checkmate okay one
king G2 and G4 yeah yeah you just want
to play King G2 here you want to just
leave of course on A5 and or H3 is an
excellent move as well here yes to not
not allow G4 at all yeah King G2 on uh
lavon's agenda
as he's he has a protected passport on
A5 very active Rook on the seventh so
just get your king out of these check
mating patterns and then it should be
easy easy game easy win and take that
night off the board I mean
and I also hear that Wesley won his game
against chefchenko by the way this is
now looking like a technical win for
white A6 followed by A7 I don't think
actually he blew it yeah sir no yes he's
not winning anymore
what happened
how did he blow it this looks so good
for white well actually after the move
Bishop E7 instead of the bishop E7 is
fine but he he had to make sure he
didn't take on G5 so he had to play the
move King takes G4 was winning and also
the idea of Rook da trading the Rooks
was Stronger instead of taking on G5 so
Bishop G5 was the big mistake and now I
think uh is going to be a lot of Contra
player Rook D4 is coming up
uh we do have some moves on the board
and looks like oh he didn't play trade
King G5 Rook A6 we can take on E6 but
King F4 is the problem and he's done it
and after Rook B6
we can go Rook to A2 threat or King
takes each looks like things are going
magnus's way because he's saving this
game and Duda is not better anymore at
all at all okay
so again if both those players draw then
Magnus wins the tournament yes but Duda
could have the last say
I like this move Rook A2 because the
move G3 is actually he didn't play Oh
Rook A5 was the threat although I might
have had a Perpetual in those case
anyway uh Rook takes A6 the very active
black king makes all the difference in
the world of our
yes that's why he's he's holding this
position Rook A3 Rook B3 and King E4 and
Black's agenda all right okay he too uh
he might also
on g3 at some point now starting G3
now threatening G3 and G no King two
he's
does anyone have any chances here does
Lavon still have a chance to win this no
I think even if you were to get your
king to A7 a series of checks is going
to drive you well if you think black's
King is kind of is this one exactly it
can't move right although in truth it
might be able to like imagine yeah you
can't even you can't even cross he could
have just played even Rook C1 Rook C1
check was it yeah no I think at some
point Magnus will just sack the rook and
take F2 exactly like I mean imagine
uh
uh you may not need to because these
checks are so annoying and white king
cannot hide exactly
I think that
anyways
the action is still toppable as Duda has
won his game it's not over till it's
over
and this one is over because uh
yeah the black king is ready to escort
the pawn G3
yeah should be saved by Magnus Bravo
great stuff great stuff which means
Magnus only has one point lead and
Magnus looks at the looked in kind of
grimaced when he saw that Duda had won
bar over to you how to do to pull that
off yeah yeah it looked like it's going
to be a draw but then somehow he managed
to win I will show you the uh ending of
that game but I wanted also to show you
the Wesley's win
so let me just show you the very end of
that game
see here
and right right right around here it
looked like it was just just gonna be a
draw
right
he won this position yeah yeah it just
looks like completely a drawn position
but he managed to trick his opponent uh
with this H6 and he got this 97 idea uh
but another game that I was watching
then he picked up the bishop still might
be a draw but there was a mistake but
Wesley saw won a crushing game and uh
kiril played the dragon and it really
really backfired pretty badly for him in
this game and Wesley actually picked up
the pawn on A7 here
at this moment which is a kind of move
that you're not completely sure if you
want to take this but he
he just he just takes Bishop A7
to now B4 Knight D5
Knight takes D5 Ed
and now Queen A5 comes in and now Bishop
D4 and in this position there was a
chance for chefchenko to play the move
Rook takes C2 wow yeah the idea is if
you take with the queen black has the
move to play Rook C8 and now black is
doing well in this position and if you
take back with the Kink then there's a
big problem with the mubish pair five
and if you take back with the bishop
then after Queen A2 black has a strong
attack but he missed this idea and he
didn't play the move Rook C2 Bishop F5
now King B1 just consolidating the
position and Wesley went on to win the
game because it still looks like you
have some pressure but he's just
defending everything
Rook D2 consolidating and he continued
with G4
again you can trade Queens because any
game will be just simply winning because
of the extra pawn and he continued with
H4 H5 open up the H file and won the
game so very good result for Wesley but
chefchenko definitely missing that nice
tactic Rooks Rook takes C2 which would
have given good chances yeah Rook C2
would have been a cold shower and it all
comes down to this let's take a look at
the standings as we go into our
Championship 18th and final round and
here we go the only two players who can
win this tournament Magnus Carlson and
Bianca yourself do that they are playing
each other and doodle will have to beat
Magnus to go into the playoffs exactly
and the third place we have Wesley so
and in the fourth and the elf and Wesley
again this Manchester points is nice
price fun he would love to finish in
clear third and the pairings in our
Championship round
Carlson and more from Poland
foreign
well actually guys there was a big big
moment uh in that game between Magnus
and Levon towards the end where we
thought that it is all written down it's
going to be a draw but in fact it wasn't
take a look at this last moment last
chance for Levon and to be honest if you
don't have a lot of time you're never
going to find this this is a mutual
suswang position if a white is moved
then it's a draw if black is to move
then this is a victory for white so
after King to F1 the only move in the
position for black to uh keep the drug
would have been Rook to B1 check now
after King to G2 I go Rook to B3 if you
go on the other side we get a very
similar position to what we got in the
game and we've seen that's an easy draw
take a look at this he played Rook to B2
he
or Rook to B1 for example now I go King
to H2 now you go Rook to B3 and I go
into G2 and you no longer have any moves
because I go King to G3 next now there's
another a little trick in the position
for example if you go once again if you
keep the Rook anywhere on the B file
except B3 I will go to H2 and then once
you land on uh B3 to try to stop me from
going to G3 I go to G2 and that's game
over wow so but take a look at this if
you give a check and now I go to H2 you
have this extra check this is the key in
the position and then you come back and
then I go back on H7
or keep an eye on this phone yes correct
and if I go to G1 try to use this
triangulation I go to H7 and that's game
over so very very nice moment here Levon
had another extra opportunity to finish
Magnus but he was unable to do so and
take a look at the opening you guys
caught the end of that game between the
United
but take a look at this opening Knight
to C3 a D6 F3 okay this I've never seen
me neither there is only one game in the
database
maybe he wants to play a knight of
streamers I will show you what he wants
I will show you what he wants he wants
to go D4 okay and after Knight to C6 he
wants to have the extra Square for the
queen on F2 Queen to F2 this is really
cool it's a very cool line I already put
my students uh to analyze this this F3
idea so they're already yes and he got a
completely winning position by the way
this is a very nice position you have an
attack on the king side you have the
nice Knight on D4 and there's no attack
for uh black but he spoiled it and in
fact he had this golden opportunity
after Queen to B5 hey just take the pawn
why not give me the pawn then I'm going
to go back to D4 and despite the fact
that I opened up the A5 yeah you have
nothing to do because normally I don't
like to take those phones I know but A3
is protecting everything it's so nice
there's there's absolutely no way that
you get my king in this position and
that's a pawn that's a very important
Pawn yes he played Bishop to D4 and in
fact
voitashek was back in the game and we
got to decent game and I thought that
he's actually the one pressing right now
and as we can see also it seems like
objectively he had a better position for
example at this point you can just play
the move A4 and stop the majority of uh
White on the queen side very important
move after that go for the uh the Knight
on H6 I'm going to pick up the pawn on
G4 and then I'm going to have the H Pawn
running and you guys saw how that game
ended Bishop to E4 and then
unfortunately for uh radoslav he was
unable to tame the Beast that dude that
is in this one and uh
yes consequences now I mean the fact
that do the one it shows that he still
is fighting for the first series yes and
I kept my eyes on the game Anish giri
played against the Richer rapper I'll
just shortly tell you that it was fill
it or defense D6 said I was laughing
yeah so Richie shows that he's not
afraid of anything in this tournament so
and danish I think he got really good
position it was just this time of
position again that either I give you a
Checkmate also yeah this is the exact
same line so they analyzed probably the
whole night yes and now they came out
with some new ideas and at the end of
the day again um Anish got really great
position but uh after many many
exchanges I think that they were both
already tired with so this was this
event I mean so here probably he could
have tried to play Maybe Rook D5 to keep
the tension or Rook D5 then take on the
seven but he decided at the end to play
rookie one and after rookie 8 take Queen
A1 they just went for the Perpetual
check so the game was finished like that
before yeah it's going to work when they
won I mean I mean you could have tried
yes yes it was like that yes
so and you could have tried maybe to
press reach more but okay Philadelphia
difference shows that CSM Blitz you can
still play and Associate it all comes
down to the last game cannot believe it
yes we couldn't you know ask for a
better question
yes I mean to have Magnus and and a
youngster of plane in the last round I
mean what else you could ask for the
chess Illuminati are definitely uh
Making Waves in this tournament I will
all comes down to the last game guys
Magnus versus do that this is going to
be absolute Madness and Duda is in a
must-win situation we're going to go on
a short break back to you actually thank
you uh Anastasia thank you Christian and
thanks to the magic of Television yes
it's competition let's take a look at
Magnus as he completes his game with
Lavon aronian he wants to make sure he's
won the tournament what he really really
wants to see is that the game of Duda
has been drawn right and let's gauge his
reaction once he realizes that it wasn't
wrong and that he has to play yes not
lose and not lose with the white pieces
but okay
I mean doodle has second place
guaranteed so he has nothing to lose on
everything to win exactly that's what
that's
what's going to make the game so
spectacular both players have secured
first and second for themselves that's
not the issue that amazing end game that
Christians showed us here that white
that was crazy
too it's unbelievable even with a lot of
time on the clock that would be hard to
find right well if levona found that I
would ask for an extra wand
it was double check the fair play rules
that they've been established by the way
the security has been great you see the
players uh all being checked as they
come in
eventually this did end up as a king
versus King and again it's that Magnus
Carlson look I guess we we got froze
as we check that out before we go to the
finals I just want to get in a big big
thanks first of all to yourselves thank
you for joining us and supporting the
show we're getting record numbers and
thank you again also big thanks to our
sponsors the superbet foundation most
especially for their sponsorship of the
competitions in both Bucharest and
Warsaw you've been terrific thank you
Gary Kasparov the grantchester founder
and uh overall Visionary if you will for
the grantchester Tony Rich here at the
St Louis chess club Michael kordakovski
for all you do to make sure the grand
chest tour is humming along the St Louis
chess club and Scholastic Center
everyone at Spectrum Studios and
everyone at Spectrum as well as
Silverback Studios thank you to our
production team thank you Tyler for
keeping us on our toes it's so
appreciative and final thanks
of course the biggest thank you to Rex
and Genie singful for making all of this
possible absolutely absolutely thank you
Rex and Genie and of course many events
still coming up on our calendar
including Jeannie's very own Karen's cup
as the top ladies of the world come to
St Louis to do battle
whoo two great events for uh as a grand
chess tour the season gets underway I
don't even want to look at the picks I
mean this has not been pretty this is uh
the last round is between Christian and
Anastasia exactly exactly uh boy I mean
Anish
I I tell you I mean it was an insightful
creative decision of me and Gary just
didn't come through that was terrible I
was dying levonne was doing so well at
some point too yeah and I thought he'd
really have a chance but just okay it
all comes down to this it's so simple
Magnus Carlson what is he going to do is
he going to play for a win to say this
is the greatest result of my life or
well I think I just wanted to play for a
draw because that does not end well it
doesn't work you play for a draw you you
get the worst position
so I think anything can happen do that
like I said before has nothing to lose
right so he just needs to choose an
interest in opening so he can get a play
right and then it's anything can happen
coach uh VAR you know these situations
so well yourself uh you've got first of
all you're very proud of yourself you
got first in the pocket or at least a
tie for first uh but you also you want
to win clear first what's your strategy
absolutely well Michael's got the white
pieces I think he should just play
normal chess without worrying about
playing some dry lines and I think Duda
is going to take a lot of chances if
Magnus just plays a good opening and
we'll see that do that take a lot of
risks because with black pieces it's
going to be very hard to beat Magnus so
I I still think Magnus is a big favorite
but definitely do that now has a shot
yeah absolutely and our tour is just
getting uh started this is our second
event and here are the upcoming GCT tour
events all right we'll see you back for
super United rapid and Blitz in a
tournament will be in Croatia in July uh
from 3rd to the 10th another Wild Card
placement for Magnus Carlson is he
enjoyed this event so much he wants to
come back for Croatia correct and then
we'll the players will be coming to St
Louis for rapid and Blitz in November
and sink Full Cup in November and
December that's too long that's way way
down the road that's too long from now
that same field cup uh event it's it's a
granddaddy of the chess tour and
everybody's really looking forward to
that but those aren't the only events
that are going to be hosted here in St
Louis we've got upcoming Classics and
again the Karen's cup is a very very
promised event uh covid
disrupted the Karen's cup so it's really
really wonderful to have that coming
back and
Duda from his perspective winning with
the black pieces on demand that's a big
ask how is he going to do it Nasi yes
but he's happy to be in this situation
where he has a chance for the first
place still so exactly defending
Champion I imagine he must have
butterflies in his stomach but
exciting game exactly now Magnus has
been playing risky chess we've seen that
in a number of his defenses that he's
been playing he's essayed a lot of
different things but but seriously From
duda's perspective
it's it's so hard to catch Magnus in the
position that maybe is a is
uncomfortable in what is going to need
magnus's help right yeah what could or
should do should he play something like
a Dutch Leningrad to create imbalance
early Evar what's yours first we have to
see the first move by Matt exactly so we
don't know what it would be it could be
C4 D4 E4 B3 Knight F3 B3 so once we see
the first one that's what he's thinking
let me see the first move and then try
to think of some kind of a setup where
there are a lot of pieces on the board
and eliminate the exchanges but I think
we'll see the first move now and here we
go and waiting the first move E4 E4 you
know sometimes we have Sicilian when you
want Oh B6 when you want to win
apparently when you want to draw as
white sometimes E4 is the way to go
because there are so many forcing Ultra
sharp lines that do end in draw now this
early B6 it it doesn't have a good
reputation for it
VAR yes I think definitely do that is
taking some risks here and there are
some some games played in a database in
the current position after the move
Queen C7 about 40 games I see white can
in fact play the move 95 try to play
Ultra aggressive and I think that makes
sense because black is still way behind
in development here so 95 attacking the
Queen Bishop takes D5 Bishop takes D5
Queen E55 I've done it by the way Knight
D5 is on the board Bishop Bishop E3 this
is very very risketting for Duda can
black take on D5 Bishop E2
now threatening Bishop F3 uh I'm not
saying I'm a pawn Grabber but I'm not
signing up for this E5 is your only move
here I think really Bishop F3 E4 uh wish
54 I think black is okay but white will
be better after the move Knight F5 I'm
still nice
good compensation here Queen E5
immediately by dude he wasn't interested
and Bishop takes D5 and Magnus saying
Bishop E3 you gotta take the Knight
because Knight takes B6 what
I was about to say Knight takes B6
apparently it's a blunder and now with
Knight F3 white is plus four
this might be a very quick game this is
very strange oh night and Duda just just
look to scans and he did not like that
move Knight F3
oh boy oh boy uh he missed it was over
before it got started yeah
it's easy to miss backward moves always
yeah that but I look Knight takes oh
Knight takes B6 Queen A5 check that was
that was the nasty trick that he had set
up Knight F3 however oh my goodness
Knight C7 check
um
Forks the king and Rook by the way it
goes to E7 oh dear me oh blimey
that is just so bad yeah why it's going
to be at material and
we have the initiative yeah compensation
right right you don't even need to rush
to take the rookie you can start out
with the move Queen D2 I'm wearing a
long Castle I was about to say Bishop E2
Queen D2 queen queen D2 has my attention
because long castles and I could go
Queen D6 check
he took the Rook can't blame him for
that the King on E7 is just pathetic
Queen D2 castles born on sagging
uh yeah everything's wrong a horrible
position for Duda yeah he can play now
c4 yeah or even Queen D4 is very good
exchange I was gonna say queen D4 looks
great
let's not forget Magnus only needs a
draw of course he's gonna play to win
this game of course
uh Queen D4
I had a question for you is there a name
for this line that Duda played in the
Sicilian early B6 on move two does it
have a name and uh I don't know maybe
there is a name but I think definitely
the smooth Queen C7 I didn't like I
would have preferred something like E6
there right and try to get you know some
kind of a position with Knight F6 yeah
but Queen C7 was just just way too risky
to allow Knight D5 B5 that invites Queen
A7 or queen C5 check
or A4 I mean anything everything looks
good for a while true that it does it
does A5 looks uh pardon me A4 looks very
very
powerful I want to say queen takes on D4
Knight takes D4 B4 trying to shut things
down but this move A5 leaves this Pawn
as a permanent weakness
okay before we write uh final passage
for Duda remember he did get a pawn for
the exchange and he does have some
squares if he could just
material right so uh the bishop A7 would
be met by Knight C6
so
Paul does he have a chance to come back
a little bit Mac has played series of
inaccurate moves guys and to do that is
actually he's okay now and uh what yeah
it was a position went from almost plus
six to right now it's like you know less
than plus one for white no kidding G5 I
still I mean Bishop takes Ace do you
think Magnus is relaxed already
I I think from magnus's point of view
he's probably thinking I've done
everything properly and well if you
hadn't told him your last few moves were
an accurate uh Magnus he wouldn't
believe you he would say I've just won
the pawn on A6 I'm cruising I don't know
what you're talking about so Rook A2 but
going from plus six to plus 0.5 that's a
big well that's a big change he just he
just doesn't know it I mean because he's
thinking and now just Knight takes B6
for Duda and then Rook B8 pick up the B6
spawn and I see some uh you know serious
compensation he played it the wrong way
though he he he attacked the bishop and
permitted it
permitted the bishop to retreat to E3
yeah it was inaccuracy because that A5
Pawn is actually going to remain on the
board now precisely and I'm not sure why
what Bishop okay sorry the bishop on A8
is hanging so you can't capture it twice
but Bishop E3 might have been far more
confounding absolutely or even Bishop
Bishop C5 check uh the force the D6 and
then go Bishop E3 because in some of
these lines Rook will come to A7 with
with the check yeah absolutely that was
just a big Advantage for white and now
after Knight D4
and Mattress may not have an advantage
but he also doesn't risk to lose this
rate and he only needs a draft it's
a
um
although again I mean now I feel the
inaccuracies are beginning to pile up
now it's less and he's one and a half
minutes behind on the clock I mean we
thought dude I was going to resign in
less than 20 minutes oh for sure sure it
looked like it was move eight or
something that Duda was looking and
disgusted at the move Knight F3 and uh
at that moment we thought it was plus
four or we were told by the engine it
was plus four now he's fighting back
yeah Wesley drew his game against dick
okay he's trying to secure his third
place but his mvl uh putting pressure
lost by the way that might be an
inaccurate information oh apologize for
that I would have to check
oh my oh my
okay and mvl
mvl is still playing unclear about equal
position Okay jump back in we just have
to move Bishop F3 by Magnus and he keeps
spoiling things
already very slightly better exactly
yeah
it takes back Rook B6 now Rook B6 he's
even included the move B3 by the way
I'm not 100 sure you needed to include
B3 because that does ensure that white
yeah and then more ponds coming off the
board and this H4 is a critical move
this is a very strong move because you
get rid of your age uh weak H Pawn and
now you exchange more pawns exactly and
this is going to give Magnus a lot more
drawing chances exactly if only there
are more pieces on the board dude I
would definitely have a chance but well
I can only imagine in the playing Hall
the Polish audience is holding their
breath
can the Polish fighter I I'm using that
term because he has a handle as the
Polish fighter on chess.com
can he snag this game Rook takes B2 here
that is a that's a confounding ending
bishop and four pawns versus rook and
two pawns the double pawns are actually
okay yes because that makes it easy to
trade but the the straight up Bishop
versus two pawns versus Rook if there
was only a bishop in two pawns I
remember uh girovich beating Larry
Christensen with the bishop in two Pawns
wow yes that can happen that can happen
against the pawns are far Advanced yeah
and yeah you have a chance but I think
here it should be comfortable draw for a
Magnus do you think that uh Duda should
be trading Roots I think he should play
E5 unhappy he was shaking his head like
how do I get here he's not happy there
winning position from the opening we we
read due to his last rights E5 and
keeping the Rook on the board
yeah I think this is the best chance for
him to play E5 but he played Bishop
B6 keeping the but we're about to see B3
that's an improvement for white that's
definitely the the pawn is no longer on
a dark Square
and uh
maybe black wants to create four passers
so D5 E5 not quite sure what the move
Rook A4 does I was more interested in
Rook going to the A8 Square so that I
could come across I think he wants to
play it oh there you go he wants to play
B4 and four some exchanges
oh Bishop uh blindness Bishop B3 Rook no
I'm not blind Bishop E3 Rook Eve
three okay yeah I I was thinking Bishop
takes Rook A7 is met by Bishop to D6 and
you're not forcing a trade of Rooks
B4
I mean I guess Duda could play Bishop D6
right away to avoid exchanges me makes
sense
I still try to push with E5
yeah I would uh
the only hope here is that Magnus goes
into some deep time trouble and then
makes a big wonder by the way I'm not a
fan of this move Bishop B6 because Rook
A8 threatens maybe winning and The Rook
B8 is a winning thread because that
bishop and Rook would be tied up to the
B2 so he needs to play Bishop C5 Bishop
C time to play Bishop C5 yes Bishop C5
Rook A5 Rook B4 oh yeah and we we get
the ending that it seems like Duda has
been trying to avoid
yeah I don't think he can keep avoiding
the exchange exactly
by the way Bishop C5 would run into Rook
D3 as well right and do this down to 10
seconds by the way Bishop C5 Rook D3 and
we can agree a draw right away Rook D3
okay five oh he missed it Magnus did
I mean this is also
why it has to try hard to lose this
where there's a will there is a way
uh Rook to C7 and just wait
the problem is G5 Pawn is weak and it's
going to be difficult to activate the
Kink and now you can play with Rook H6
Rook H6 followed by Rook G6 I like that
keep an eye on that E6 Pawn exactly
I like that very much that would uh by
the way is the clock a factor yet
um
in seconds wow okay it feels like to me
that dude has achieved more or less the
maximum he can play D5
pardon me yes D5 followed by D4
and
well okay G4 check
D4 is time to take the pawn
it's very hard for him to create a pass
Pawn
and I see that mvl won his game
again because I think that allows mdl to
catch Wesley in a tie for third and this
was the ending I was asking you about
for
um King
and Rook versus the bishop and the two
Pawns
I have seen uh again uh not Dimitri
gurvich the other gervich and I'm trying
to remember its name
thank you so much yes
Michael guravich and what Michael did
was very clever he he was passing around
for 40 moves and got Larry thinking then
he would Advance upon play another 40
moves
torture uh poor Larry but D4 okay what
does the table base tell us it's it
shows it's just equal here but in time
travel it's
the idea is if you play D3 I have King
E3 I think now he needs to just stay on
the fifth rank this is yeah just stay on
the fifth rank now yeah that's the
problem but this move D this move
threatened D3 check followed by E3
and what about King C4 and D3 King C4
okay four now I'm sorry
there's a moment of nervousness there
as again due to dude is the one with
chances obviously well two seconds for
Magnus so
wow
King C4 and it's getting scary D3 check
it is winning now the table based Talent
is telling the jump it's a win but no
Bishop G3 was a miss
Bishop D6 was winning
oh my God it's still winning no are we
gonna see a playoff
winning to a draw that's what table uh
bass is telling me
wow wow
anything can happen in Blitz okay what
does your intuition tell you and I'll
see I think we're gonna be a playoff I
think it'll be a draw
VAR yes I think it should be a draw with
the correct defense here
and uh let's see three seconds for two
you got to keep the Rook on D3 so if E3
comes you can take
wow
how does white claim it during this
situation you have to yeah you say to
the Arbiter uh I'm claiming 50 moves now
if you're draw claim is unaccepted then
your opponent gets extra time was that a
mistake
no I think it's still fine still fine
now King C3 but there were three or four
times
no Rook d8 check
oh
Magnus how many seconds this Magnus has
10 seconds dude that has five
whoa whoa whoa whoa and
it's incredible that Duda had a win more
than once here
Rook I was about to say Rook check and
Rook to E4 Rook to D5 sorry again
Rook to D7 yeah Rook D7 Rook D3 yet yeah
three right yes
okay don't lose your Rook
check
the seven King C4 that's right
oh my gosh
and playing this position with no time
on the clock and defending I want to say
heroically this is a really impressive
play by Magnus Rook
so he needs to keep the king cut off for
as long as he can exactly we're up to B5
pushes E3 he has Rook a three right
forcing oh down to one second one second
both of them at various moments there
just went down to one second
imagine if one of them Flags if Magnus
Flags this oh my goodness
I'm predicting playoffs everybody you
heard it here first
still table Bay still showing intro of
course still showing the draw but now
the threat is E3 Magnus found
one of the drawing moves
he's playing very accurately
with almost with no time no time and by
the way this looks like a three-time
repetition I feel like I've seen this
this this position before but it's hard
to claim that so
for sure it is impossible and that's
that's bad draws the game oh oh wow
that was a great fight you gotta do that
yeah he came back from a terrible
opening and nearly pulled it off I was
wrong my Almighty that serves this
tournament is failed I I caught a
playoff
Magnuson finally relaxed and take a deep
breath
wow and I just got a fog Magnus we just
had one they made 124 moves
124. in a Blitz game that was one of the
finest performance in the rapid and
Blitz that we've seen on the grand
Chester we've had some amazing amazing
performances but that what he scored and
what did he score finally in the rapid
and Blitz bar plus uh in a blitz in a in
the blitz portion I think his plus was
just absolutely huge see it plus he won
seven in a row then I think it was like
I think even more well yeah but even
more importantly forty thousand dollars
richer our congratulations to Magnus for
winning their super bad rapid and Blitz
and Duda did not give up his crown
lightly no he fought until the very end
that is for sure wow a very very
deserving Champion indeed that Jan
Christophe Duda as he pushed Magnus to
his limit even though Magnus just ran
away with the blitz portion
he's such a bad start in the rapid first
game loss and then in Blitz such
dominating performance
impressive let's take a look at the
final standings for the tournament and
uh here we have them Magnus Carlson
winning and still in the 13 grandchild
store points from the players absolutely
a young Christoph Duda a second clear
second place and winning 10 grandchester
points and thirty thousand dollars as
well all right and sharing third Wesley
so and mvl and taking seven and a half
grandchild store points and 22 and a
half thousand dollars very very nice our
Wild Card Player Lavon aronian very
solid finish and the fifth place uh
grabbing oh still in six points from the
grand historical exactly and taking home
fifteen thousand dollars and really uh
pushing uh the other players
a rich report finishing in the sixth
place Anish giri 7th and kiril bhaktan
and Rado slash finish in 8 9 and 10. and
uh congratulations to Carol because uh
his rapid chess performance was not
spectacular but in Blitz he was showing
everybody that he was a force to be
reckoned with very very young as well so
congratulations to the players and their
standings
and to remind everybody more chess
coming your way including Zagreb super
United wrapping and Blitz in July
players will be playing in Croatia and
then later this year they'll be coming
to St Louis for rapid and Blitz and the
singled cup exactly and for in that
final game did the table base show a win
for Duda I think macros is probably
holding maybe at one point there was a
chance but I think Magnus defended
incredibly well despite the fact he was
playing on seconds yes a couple of times
he made a move with one second on the
clock and but he just held it so it was
it was amazing defense I think so many
people would have just plundered and
lose that game and then with the feather
playoffs
wow uh very very very impressive uh
there I'm learning how to play in games
one of the things I wanted to say that
in my time we had the adjournments and
so we did play very accurately the
endings thanks to the Germans these
players with almost as you just saw were
seconds on their clocks they're still
playing incredibly accurately
nine eight rounds where you're exhausted
absolutely exhausted yes wow uh just
just just uh again spectacular stuff
and let's uh go to the closing
ceremonies in Warsaw with Christian
thanks guys after five days of
exhilarating chest it is finally time to
Crown our 2023 Superbad rapid and Blitz
Champion we are joined by Adam
lamentovich the CEO of Superbad Poland
and Michael kodarkovski the executive
director of the grand Chester Michael
I'm going to give you the first word
thank you Christian yes last round was
to the wire and we are very happy that
Magnus Carlsen who is number one world
chess player and five-time World
Champion uh one second leg of the grand
chess tour here in Warsaw and I would
like to congratulate Magnus on this
achievement and once again it's it was
thrilling uh event and we're looking
forward to see Magnus in zagrip in the
third leg and he actually has good good
memories about Zagreb most likely he
will be looking forward to make third
third in in Zagreb as well after 2019
and 2020 2022 and again congratulations
to Magnus and congratulations to
everyone uh who were watching and to all
chess community and of course I would
like to thank our sponsors from superbet
here and looking forward to Third Leg in
Zagreb
Adam
please present the trophy to our
champion Magnus Magnus great congrats
the last game was really really very
exciting and and the whole tournament
and really thanks for joining us here
and I hope Poland will bring only warm
and good memories to you
um it was a great event uh definitely
looking forward for the next year and
inviting you all to uh to Zagreb as
Michael already said so thanks a lot and
really great great job and a great
achievement again you know thanks again
thank you and we will pass this to
Magnus Magnus first of all tell us your
initial thoughts and your initial
feelings everybody's hearts are pounding
right now how about yours yeah for sure
um
I I could it's it's one of those things
you know when you can feel your energy
sleeping like a little bit when a day
goes like at the start I was playing
with more flow and it was was easier
um and then with three rounds to go I
could feel or I could already like feel
in the fifth six games that I was not
feeling as energetic anymore uh and then
I was like hoping like
uh
I was already like starting to think
about the last game
um like I really I was really hoping
that I wouldn't have to
get a result in that game but uh to do
less credit like he kept going and even
in the last game uh I think he made a
poor opening choice because these
um dubious lines that's really my
territory so I generally it was like
that's that's the stuff I actually
actually know but like he dug in after
that and he played extremely well uh and
uh I really had to fight so hard like of
course A lot of it was self-inflicted
but still like if he if he doesn't play
as well as he as he did like in the in
the last three four games this there
wouldn't have been a thrilling
conclusion but you know happy to come go
I don't know after the second day a lot
of people were writing you off you were
trailing behind by quite a few points
why did you tell yourself at that point
to get yourself back in the tournament
no as I said earlier like I played a few
Blitz Games online and I was doing well
and I I just needed one when really uh
and after that I thought
um I mean already on the third day I was
feeling like
I was feeling in normal shape so I
thought
um
mainly I just thought that's that's good
I can actually play chess and whether
I'd be able to compete for a tournament
Victory I didn't think about at that
point because it was
um too early and not realistic and I
mean even with um
even with uh plus 10 and uh Blitz it was
still close so
um but uh but yeah I'm very very happy
happy of course and with the tournament
like not training all the time was kind
of um uh was was not so was not so bad
it meant that I I didn't have any reason
to think about the tournament standing
so I could just play did you relax uh
once you took the lead
um yeah not really uh
I mean going in
going to the last day I sort of felt
that if I have a good day I'll win
um
since I thought for do that there will
be extra pressure and it wouldn't be so
so easy but I wouldn't necessarily I I
would say I was pretty relaxed the first
few rounds but that was more of like
being
um being in decent shape and
playing playing well rather than leading
and finally you have so many supporters
around the world and here in Poland as
well your final message to them and your
coach perhaps as well your family tell
us a bit about that
I mean obviously thanks all for for
following and uh it's uh nice to to show
that my uh retirement only lasted a
couple of days
Magnus congratulations you are the 2023
super bad rapid and Blitz champion thank
you guys for the final time back to you
in the studio in St Louis thank you
Christian an instant classic quote by
Magnus they're critical of judah's
dubious openings as he said that is my
territory
yeah my specialty as we take one last uh
glance at the very standings oh oh and
we're now seeing how at the end after
Magnus won his reaction
yeah there he is as he's saying okay I
got away with one and thank you and
that's because you were saying move 72
through 74 of this game between Magnus
and Duda was a chance that Duda did
according to our table basis have a win
so he was that close and these are the
final standings
right we have the champion Magnus
Carlson not taking home any electricity
points because he's the Wild Card taking
the Forty thousand dollars very nice uh
in the second place young Christoph Duda
taking home 10 grandchester points uh
third place sharing Wesley sewing and VL
with seven and a half granchester Point
twenty two thousand five hundred dollars
Richard thank you and Livonia not taking
any GCT points but it's a wild card
fifteen thousand dollars uh Richard
report picking up Five Points Anish giri
picking up four points and the last
three were wild cards absolutely and our
congratulations but let's take a look at
the GCT standings now that we've got two
events of the tour in on in the history
books so coming into this Fabiano was in
the lid exactly and now two players have
passed him Wesley so with 15
15.3 granchester points right young
Christoph Duda with
14.5 and Fabi was 13. Richard very close
12.8 and bl was 12 points an ish 11.8
Ali reisha firoza 7.8 and our new world
champion Dean clearance so far only
three points and the only published two
points you can imagine those two players
wanting to Roar they're back and here we
have it our congratulations from all of
us at the production here in the St
Louis chess club at Scholastic Center
you are the champion maggots yes
congratulations and thank you for
entertaining us oh such exciting games
VAR sum it up please I mean it was very
very exciting dude that played great I
mean from the very bad position he
really you know improved the position
and push Crossing to the Limit I was
analyzing a little bit he did probably
have a win around that move 72 to 74 but
it was very very hard even after putting
it in it's not easy so but great fight
by Duda and finishing second place is a
great result for him as well but of
course Magnus just absolutely incredible
in a blitz portion of this tournament so
congratulations to him absolutely and to
sum up thank you both I mean it was
really a great pleasure working uh with
uh
I mean I know this was your rookie
outings with Bucharest but I think at
the end of it you become season Pros uh
you were really really great thank you
it was my honor my pleasure and as you
just saw there Karen's Cup coming up
June 3rd to 13th that's next on our
agenda we'll hope you hang out with us
and join the show will you be back for
the kids I'll be back I'll see you again
all right right very good goodbye
everyone thank you so much
[Music]
foreign
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited